the big news today is that a reporter
for the Washington Post has doxed the
Creator behind the popular Twitter
account Libs of tick tock this is a an
account that criticizes the left and
often highlights publicly available
posts from these people it's really
interesting that this is considered a
bad thing like somebody posts a video on
Tick Tock somebody else shares it
they're like stop sharing it it's like
you meant for it to be shared you posted
on social media the interesting thing
about the story is that shortly after it
was published there was a major backlash
among many on the right because not only
was the name of the person who created
the account published but also their
private home address now there's a lot
to get into into the Nuance of what that
means but we here at timcast our great
reporters dug through some public
records and sure enough the address that
they they linked to was listed as the
private residence of the creator of Libs
of tick tock there is a lot to go
through there so let me just stress it
there's more Nuance more context
The Washington Post came out
like not too not too long ago a couple
hours ago I think saying we never link
to any of their private details which is
the craziest and boldest outright lie
because we have the archival article
and it's got the link I can click the
link and show you the address I'm not
going to but it's remarkable that they
think they can just outright lie like
this so you know what to talk about you
know the media is dying CNN plus latest
update there they laid off CNN CFO is
laid off their uh Discovery apparently
is like this is a flop Netflix just
tanked like what 25 in their stock uh
what else do we got we got oh Jon
Stewart's new show
forty thousand viewers forty and and
here's the best part not even viewers
they called it homes homes that means
like literally no one might be watching
Jon Stewart's show get what go broke man
so we got that we've got to uh and also
in the media an Ethics complaint
potentially against gen saki because
she's disparaging Fox News while
negotiating a contract with MSNBC really
interesting Media stuff here and then we
got some other stuff related to uh black
lives matter they're accused of what
being the reason behind a major spike in
murders or something like that so we'll
talk about all that plus Joe Biden has
uh apparently announced gonna be running
again it's gonna be a wild show and we
have a lot to talk about with the
Washington Post doxing this is reporter
Taylor Lorenz yes she literally doxed a
a uh somebody and and it's considered
very hypocritical because she recently
has said doxing is wrong so we'll get
into the Nuance of this uh joining us
today is of course Jack besobic
ladies and gentlemen welcome aboard
tonight's edition of Tim cast promoting
your new book I see promoting my new
book this new book is called by pillow
and yeah it is written by by Pillow um
in conjunction with promo code
postomypillow.com and essentially it's
just every word on the page on the first
page on the left it says buy and on the
right it says pillow all the way through
the book is this like your new
catchphrase by Pillow just it is pretty
good
what's the plot of the book
it's an epic
um
Saga I don't know man it put me to sleep
as intended the book itself actually is
a pillow yeah we also have functions
Sheamus I'm back uh it was you know a
wonderful Easter weekend for me it's
great to be back and see all you people
Today's Show they come spiritual too
what's up everybody although I do
disagree the media is dying I think it's
transmuting into what we have here we
mean the corporate I agree with you
there I gotta say tonight is the night
the official
announcement of the theory of the
twisting Universe oh up to this point
people have believed that the universe
is expanding I think there's better
evidence to show that it's actually
twisting around on itself did you make
this up it came to me in a dream my man
I've been thinking about this a lot over
the last six months and I had a
conversation with Michael malice
yesterday that really kind of nailed
some pieces in so I I brought a graphic
I'm going to talk about it later in the
show were you high I don't think so I
mean I kind of always am I think it
stays in your fat for years or something
all right well we'll talk about that
what's going on lady president I am
pressing buttons I'm very excited to
hear about the twisting universe theory
I'm curious if it aligns with our donut
Earth theory Earth is both Hollow and
flat that's right yeah this is what I'm
saying is the maker the makers of
Twister were on to something yeah they
were tapping into the very fabric of
space-time oh they're ripping me apart
with your ideas
let's let's stop having fun and talk
about serious stuff no I'm kidding we'll
have fun before we get started my
friends head over to timcast.com become
a member because we are going to have a
members only segment coming up for you
just after the show but more importantly
as a member you are funding the
reporting we do and this morning this is
a big part of the story this morning
when the story came out the narrative
among you know journalists and politicos
and commentators was that this reporter
for the Washington Post had revealed the
name
of this creator of course the original
article actually did docs the address of
the Creator we did some digging here at
timcast.com and found uh through public
records searches I wouldn't call it
difficult but I wouldn't call it easy
there's easy you know public record
search and there's like medium a little
bit more than normal but we did discover
the address they posted and then quickly
removed was the private home address of
the Creator I bring this up now because
we're gonna get into it but if you
really do respect the reporting we're
doing and challenging the the lies and
the manipulations then we need your
support as members because that's how we
fund our reporters and we have on the
ground reporters we do not sell stories
we don't make money off the stories we
cross our fingers and hope that you
believe in us enough and respect the the
news that we report so that you'll
become a member and help us make more
it's a pay what you will model and it's
a risky business model but I think it's
the right business model because I don't
want to hide important information or
put explosive details like this behind
paywalls so we just do bonus segments as
a sort of you know extra so become a
member don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show we're already we already have
more daily active users than CNN but
alas it is now being reported that CNN
actually does have 150 000 subscribers
so they're definitely bigger than us but
with your help sharing this video will
be bigger than them at that point as
well let's read this first story from
timcast.com
Washington Post publishes home address
of popular critic of left Libs of tick
tock reporter Taylor Lorenz has
previously claimed to suffer from PTSD
from being doxed in a similar way
now I want to show you a little bit here
and I got to explain a lot of the Nuance
all right they say an article by a
technology report at the Washington Post
provided the home address of the creator
of the libs of tick tock Twitter account
an article meant to expose the person
behind the popular account reporter
Taylor Lorenz linked to a critical piece
of information that disclosed the
private home address of the person
running Libs of tick tock after the
ensuing backlash the post removed the
link Tim cast confirmed that the address
published is documented as the Creator's
private home address now I will say we
were all in The Newsroom going over this
investigating details everybody kind of
contributed to uh working on this story
and we did end up pulling public records
which confirmed the original story
published by The Washington Post
contained a link to two different links
to two addresses one address was the
address of the creator of Libs of tick
tock the other address was the address
of family members now here's the
challenge if I pull up the archive to
prove they're lying about this it will
expose the name of the creator of Libs
of tick tock which I don't want to do
well I suppose we have no choice well
it's kind of like showing cuties to talk
about how bad cuties is no no look The
Washington Post published a lie should
we show their lie and prove them lying I
don't think we should show well I think
I think you can show no not the address
no no you can show the oh wait is it in
the screenshot in in the tweet from The
Washington Post where they lie right
they use the name of the creator of Libs
of tick tock right there you can at
least show the I believe the screenshot
of the original article which shows the
hyperlink it shows it still is the name
there see they put the names for every
they put the name everywhere I think
this is on Purpose By the way I think I
think it's by Design I think it's silly
for us at this point to be like people
can't find the name yeah exactly anybody
can look at my Twitter account right now
and Washington Post I think we don't
need to show it people believe us if you
really don't believe us go search for
yourself I think that's I think it's
we're being ridiculous at this point to
be like oh we're not going to say the
name even though literally it's all over
Twitter everywhere it's trending well
even Steven Crowder mentioned it the
Eric the Eric caramello
Crowder did Crowder did say uh the name
of the the Creator yeah he did well then
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna go
with it yeah so uh we have this from
Christine karate Kelly statement from
Cameron Barr re-reporting from Taylor
Lorenz they said Taylor Lorenz is an
accomplished and diligent journalist
whose reporting methods comport entirely
with the Washington post's Professional
Standards Chaya reichen in her
management of the libs of tick tock
Twitter account and in media interviews
has had significant impact on public
discourse and her identity had become
public knowledge on social media we did
not publish or link to any details about
her personal life Cameron Barr senior
managing editor of the Washington Post
Tim Poole can confirm that is a lie I
tweeted this is the game they play
effing evil people as evil as they come
there's the archive there's your proof
sorry to Libs of tick tock for dealing
with this but wapo needs to be exposed
and proven to be Liars here is the
archive of the first version of their
story and I'm gonna read it it is
archive.ph capital B lowercase e capital
V I believe it's an L lowercase L and
lowercase o and they linked to right
here if I click that right now it will
show you the address of Libs of tick
tock we pulled up private we pulled up
public records it was a a paid public
records search a little bit deeper than
you normally go and confirmed this is
documented as the private home residence
of the creator of Libs of tick tock I I
apologize that we've come to this point
we had we had deep ethical uh conundrums
and debates in The Newsroom about
whether or not we expose The Washington
Post having done this because we're
effectively amplifying their docs by
doing so but I said anything that
happens at this point is on the
Washington Post anything bad that
happens is on them and we need to call
it out because
if we say nothing they are not held to
account for having done it that being
said it is possible this is no longer
the current address of the individual
there's other other issues at play but
they also published another address
which is the We Believe based on report
of the reporting that we've done is the
family address of the individual now
you're crossing the line for what reason
did they have to do that now I reached
out to Taylor Lorenz and said we can
confirm you published the private home
address of the creator of Libs of tick
tock do you have a comment to which you
responded I did not so she's saying she
posted a link to it and that's the hill
they're going to die on it's not they're
saying it's not the same that also as I
did not no no because in the statement
it says link right it says we did not
link to so in the statement so in the
statement from Taylor to you she's
saying I did not publish in the
statement from The Washington Post which
came out like 12 hours after the actual
article itself went live they claim they
did not link after they themselves
positively went into the archive removed
the link which we can only now see in
the archive version
that's right so they're lying about
doing it Taylor is lying about doing it
I suppose her only argument is that she
doesn't believe
it's the private home address
but I I'm sorry uh how would she know
that did she actually I asked her
I I didn't I didn't just ask you know
why did you do this I sent a comment and
um because I gotta be honest I'll give
Taylor this respect she responds every
time there's been an issue she's
responded she's actually corrected
things before so I can respect that and
I said we're going to be publishing the
story I can confirm you published the
private home address of the creator of
Libs of tick tock I asked two questions
why was the link removed and did you
check the address in the link you posted
before publishing it and a response was
I did not publish the private home
address and then directed me to
Washington Post PR if that's the only
thing she has to say I can only respond
with that is an incorrect statement
outright falsifiable because I I'm not
going to publish the documents that we
have because it's a paid search you can
dig up public records that are not
it's publicly available but it's through
like a paid investigator investigative
service to get these records like you'd
have to go and physically like ask and
just like go to the county or something
we got them we're not going to publish
them but I I can say it's a statement to
fact Washington Post did publish the
Privacy
is her contention because this has to do
with the fact that
um Libs I guess was a real estate
salesperson and that this was the
registered address of her as a business
entity working as a realist working in
real estate sales retailers trying to
hide behind me even if that's the case
what is the good in publishing that why
would you have any reason to do so in
order to do an expose well it's at the
very least I'm trying to understand but
let me let me I want to make sure we get
to the real Nuance here the real context
the link they published was a real
estate license which had the address of
an LLC right however the address used by
the LLC is actually a split building
with with multiple apartments and a
storefront on Google Maps the storefront
is a salon so I said okay well wait a
minute it is common for people to use
their own address for their LLC yeah all
the time regardless of whatever reason I
have no idea why there's other employees
listed within the LLC that address we
did the record search and it and it's
it's it is listed in public records as a
private residence of this individual so
that's on the Washington Post if they
would like to explain that feel free to
as it stands right now we pulled public
records it's a private home address and
they published the address anyone else
can do it and anything that happens at
this point is on the Washington Post for
doing it I've got to point out some some
I guess Nuance because posting something
and posting a link to something or
different as an a social media
administrator and if someone posts
something illegal they go to jail if
someone posts a link to it they're
allowed to not true well it is as an
admin you don't you remove the original
piece but you don't Hammer everyone that
retweeted it that's insane we're not
talking about we're not talking about
sharing a post we're talking about them
taking the link to the address and
putting it in the article was this not
already public information it so
the name of the individual is not public
so they put some pieces together so if
no one knows the name of the person then
it doesn't matter what is public if you
then say here's their name and here's a
link to their address you've doxed them
you've published your address and I
gotta be honest that is the nuclear bomb
of doxing but but they're trying to
argue this is not dachshund when you
post their name and then with a link
next to it saying here's their home
address you've doxed is that illegal no
no maybe it should be in the 21st
century free speech the the thing that
the thing that I think we do need to add
though is that the Washington Post is
not the one that did all this work and
Taylor La Rend is not certainly not the
one who did all this work she's
piggybacking off of work that was done
by pro-antifa accounts over the weekend
people that have been doxing
um online accounts on the right and
conservatives for years with uh ongoing
harassment campaigns some of which by
the way were starting to hear may
receive foreign Government funding
well well I can't what I can say is
what is what is very much ignored by
this is that Taylor Lorenz did receive
information from activists published it
as if it was her story and used the The
Washington Post Matthew Iglesias of
vox.com which is a left-wing publication
he's no longer with them anymore but
this is yeah he's one of the people who
started it but then he left yeah he said
get a great take
is that this article is basically framed
as Libs of tick tock bad but that it
provides you with no real thesis or
argument as to why that's the case
there's no story it's basically it is
activism masquerading as news yes yeah
there is no story he said it turns out
the Crux of the story who is this person
turns out she's a random crank of no of
you know no public notoriety so why was
that relevant this is um do you remember
when they docs when uh I think it was
BuzzFeed carpi Duncan oh and and they
said oh the pro-trump meme maker and
they found that he's a stay-at-home
father of four who lives in Kansas City
he's just like a regular guy I mean he
raises his kids and makes memes as
opposed to Sheamus who raises other
people's children thank you
uh but but you lift them up Sheamus what
do you mean all the children of earth oh
I gotta I gotta I gotta pull something
up real quick when you go to the spj
ethics code and uh I think I'm gonna
have to shrink this so you can see it
there we go you can see minimize harm in
large black bold letters and it says
recognize that legal access to
information differs from an ethical
justification to publish or broadcast it
here we go this is the society for
professional journalists standard of
Ethics now there's others there's
Reuters I think the AP has theirs but
this is spj which is what they teach you
in schools and um the point being
brought up here is you minimize harm
within minimize harm they literally say
just because information may be public
or you have legal access to it does it
mean you should broadcast it which is
the challenge we had in our Newsroom
because we're like we can confirm this
is a private home address but do we do
we push that up because that'll that'll
that'll potentially cause harm you know
this is real quick it was a coin toss
for us we ultimately decided that the
Public's right to know what major
corporations are doing with the power of
billionaires outweighed the potential
harms because the harm of not exposing
this was greater than the harms of the
individual so with that you know I
apologize to Libs of tick tock for being
caught up in this but we are not the
ones who posted it's a tough one because
do you expose Medusa to the crowd to
show them that it's Medusa because if
you if they see it they'll Turn to Stone
well I mean and what are they exposing
this person makes videos on the internet
that make fun of other people in fact
they're not even doing that they're just
posting other things that people have
said which were already ridiculous
thanks there would be a story if there
were some I don't know funded effort
behind this that was being obfuscated or
if there were some nefarious you know
organization behind the lips something
like that but there's no story here
there's no story whatsoever this is the
point I brought up earlier
what is served by saying the two words
that is the private name of the
individual nothing now
the story could be the person running
the account was at January 6th as
reported I think that's new I think
that's relevant interesting what is the
what are the motivations of this person
right the opinions of the individual
also oh okay so this person also said
these things that's relevant but you can
tell that story without saying their
name saying the name only serves to
maximize potential harm well so what I
was gonna say this is the opposite
argument that you hear in uh that came
up in the katanji brown Jackson hearings
when she was talking about some of the
decisions an articles she had written
when she was in law school regarding sex
offender Registries and the idea being
that if you make a mistake once in your
life it shouldn't follow you for the
rest of your life forever so the idea
was to minimize harm to potential sex
offense or to convicted sex offenders
that over time you would be able to
reduce the amount of time essentially
that you would appear in the registry
that's the exact argument that that was
being made for sex offenders right
versus this one which is minimize harm
completely for just the subjects of
Journalism so Taylor wrens right is is
maximizing harm to someone who runs
an aggregator of again public videos
that are already out there videos again
that are made to be shared and obviously
it's you know it's not it's not
hypocrisy it's hierarchy that's kind of
the main thing the main thrust of all
this because we can say all day long
that oh it's hypocrisy you're doing
you're exposing you're writing you're
doing all this stuff but it's it's not
hypocrisy it's hierarchy they're allowed
to do it Taylor Lorenz is allowed to do
it uh because she is of the anointed
class she is of the upper class she is
of the aristocracy and the fact the
matter is that because lives of tick
tock was not anointed she didn't go to
the right school she didn't get the
right credentials she was doing this
unauthorized then she's not allowed to
because keep in mind Taylor Lorenz used
to be a Tick-Tock journalist herself and
she would go in specifically posting
videos from kellyanne Conway's 13 year
old daughter and all sorts of other
people across Tick Tock and Instagram
and she was doxing Pamela Geller's
daughters at the same time this is what
she did at the end of the day Taylor
Lorenz is jealous that Libs of tick tock
was able to become more influential and
more effective and more do more
long-lasting reporting just from looking
at Tick Tock videos than Taylor Lorenz
will ever do in her entire life
you said earlier that there was like
foreign actors potentially involved with
activist groups that are working in the
doxing yeah is that confirmed or is this
just stuff you've heard it is convert do
you have evidence is there evidence
around that we can pull up or is it is
it something we should we should we
should wait until we have a bigger Story
the release yeah that's because I don't
want to get into yeah it's not it's not
research on there yeah I like building
up sources for this it is a rabbit hole
but the idea is that the person who
conducted the initial docs is actually
receiving funding from foreign
governments well we've talked about this
before the Washington Post is not
exactly the most reputable and
responsible publication out there so I'm
sure you all remember that these are the
people who spread the uh mistruths about
Nick Sandman and part of why I'm
bringing that up right now is because
even though you mentioned it isn't
necessarily illegal for them to link to
the information they link to we could
all agree it's extremely irresponsible
and when you looked at the Nick salmon
case there's sort of a similar situation
where they made the entire country hate
this kid and then in the name of the
story The Covington school kids they
told you where he went to school so it
would be very easy for someone to find
and hurt him in the people he was with
based on that information
did he Sue Washington Post too I believe
he sued Washington Post and attempted to
sue CNN but I can double check this out
let's talk about why this is happening
so we have the story from the New York
Post Jon Stewart's new show on Apple TV
is reportedly a flop well what happened
um Jon Stewart got woke went broke look
at Bill Maher Bill Maher has been
resisting and trying to pull back but
still pretty much playing The
Establishment game but he's been calling
out wokeness and he's sort of maintained
an audience he's also never retired Jon
Stewart tried to make a comeback smack
talks white people in the problem with
white people gets panned for it and you
know what I think I think most of you
watching used to watch Jon Stewart I
used to watch Jon Stewart now I see him
come back get well go broke let's talk
about this we were just talking about
Libs of tick tock what is Libs of tick
tock well the reality is it was an
aggregator it was a lens that was
aggregating the woke left the insane
things they say and do and presenting
them in a feed
this was a powerful tool in the culture
War showing regular people what was
going on it resulted in Outrage among
parents it resulted potentially in laws
getting passed now why would they try to
Target the individual and try to destroy
their lives because wokeness is not
popular and it cannot win without Brute
Force trying to destroy when Jon Stewart
tries to get woke it fails that's what
they say get well go broke right so they
have to like is this the funny thing if
someone is showing people what woke
people are like they have to shut it
down they're like don't well people
because people are mocking it but Jon
Stewart's version of being woke was
meant to be a serious prominent
personality trying to get you to believe
in woke things and it's not working now
I remember he one of the first things he
came out against was calling Harry
Potter anti-semitic and then he went on
this whole sort of like retconning of
that where he actually went in and had
them change the video title on the
YouTube card
um in order because it's originally oh
that's right write the Goblins
anti-Semitism in Harry Potter and then
he changed it to just anti-semitic
tropes and he said no I wasn't saying
that Harry Potter was anti-semitic I was
just saying that these tropes show up
inside of Harry Potter's he's totally
different so it's like right well it's
like he doesn't know how to be woke
because he's saying the wizard himself
character yes no he called he's like I
think he's a great wizard I'd even say a
grand wizard that Harry Potter but I
wasn't calling him racist in any way
well I think well there's kind of been a
lot of Jon Stewart worship for some
bizarre reason over the past couple
years and I think that's because when
comparing him to John Oliver or Trevor
Noah he's significantly less funny but
I've heard a lot of people say things
like when Jon Stewart was the person
making informational left-wing comedy it
was all fantastic but I gotta be honest
he very much did the uh clown nose on
clown nose off thing that we've
sometimes complained about I remember he
was getting into an argument with Tucker
Carlson a couple years ago and it was a
very was it on CrossFire that's right it
was a viral clip and he's going on about
all this misinformation Carlson is
spreading and Tucker says well you've
spread a lot of misinformation on your
show and his response is it's a comedy
show and I'm sorry but when you're
presenting yourself as a comedy show
that spreads information to help keep
people informed you don't get to fall
back on I was just kidding when you get
the facts wrong so we did an episode
about a year ago
um when Luke was here and he and I got
into it over this over Kelly Stewart um
if you guys remember that you weren't
here that night but I think you three
were yeah and I was essentially making
this argument and Luke was saying Ron
Paul he needed some of these other
things and I said look no he was the
Leading Edge of that he was always the
Leading Edge of the weaponization of
comedy and now it's gone far beyond the
seeds that he initially said I I can
agree you know I think it's it's silly
to look back and trying to romanticize
the the era of Jon Stewart but he
praised project Veritas and this is a
really good example of at the bare
minimum of how things were different
he he mocked James O'Keefe for wearing a
silly outfit outfit but that's fine you
know he was he was taking Jabs at James
for dressing up the way he did and it
was actually like the normal clothes
James was wearing I forgot what he said
but uh what did he call it I don't know
but uh he basically was like journalists
where are you how are you getting
scooped by these guys which is you know
he showed the acorn reporting
legitimately like look at this and he
didn't call James O'Keefe a liar he
didn't say it was deceptively edited he
said wow look what these guys
accomplished at the very least you have
that now we're in the media age where
Trump gets not a single good day where
everything James O'Keefe does is
deceptively edited but is James it but
okay has Jon Stewart done that lately
well no no Jon Stewart because he shared
a project Veritas he was retired for
several years back now woke and broke he
cares might not literally broke
figuratively broke yeah my point is he's
that Leading Edge he's still that
Leading Edge yeah I mean I I just want
to say I know you were going to say
something
um but I just want to drop this in there
first before we we potentially shift to
something else it's not to say that Jon
Stewart's been wrong about everything
he's ever done or everything he's ever
said it's just that like you said he was
on the the Leading Edge of all of this
and whenever somebody comes out and says
something even remotely sensible
conservatives go oh this guy gets it
he's great he's our guide yeah it's
really frustrating Bill Maher yeah I was
gonna bring up when store went on the
Jack Dorsey The Tonight Show with
Stephen Colbert is that he does a
Tonight Show now
um and was talking about the coronavirus
and the Wuhan laboratory of bat
coronaviruses across the street from the
market where they told us they found the
best coronavirus the Hershey that was
like chocolate the most sensible aware
normal human Ops observation I was like
good Jon Stewart we all had within like
one week or even one day of hearing
about uh the Wuhan lab we said oh
there's a coronavirus right across the
street from a virus Factory I know it
was it's hysterical that saying that
it's possible that the virus that
originated right outside of a virus
Factory it was insane to say
um maybe that came from the virus
Factory and it was sensible to say that
it mutated in a bat and then someone ate
the soup and that's how it all happened
exactly now when Jon Stewart came out
some out of retirement disheveled on
Colbert saying all these things we were
like John Stewart's back he's going to
call out the media for being dumb and
then what did he do got up on his show
and said the problem with white people
right and we were like oh here we go the
anti-Semitism of Harry Potter happened
I've never heard him use that language
before I'll tell you what here's what I
think Bill Maher on his show he saw the
tides because he was sitting in it he
saw people tweeting him he probably
talked to people and they were like dude
you're getting these things wrong and he
was like but those are conservative
things and they're like listen you
probably went hmm so Bill Maher I think
is trying to play Both Sides call out
the welt because it won't goes too far
but don't actually entertain the fact
the left is so far gone that Bill Maher
is conservative by by today's like if
they call me a conservative Bill Morris
to the right of me on a bunch of things
but I think Bill Maher recognized that
and so he's like I'm going to call out
the woke a little bit Jon Stewart comes
back from his semi-retirement and he's
like okay what am I doing and they're
like here's what's happening if you want
to be a liberal guy and he went I'll
just say whatever I have to say to be
relevant and so he was like okay what's
that people don't like white people
let's do a show about it
and then sure enough it turns out people
actually don't like any of that stuff
they don't like what Jon Stewart's
presenting on I think a really good
example
to understand the blue checks are wrong
and crazy is that when the mask mandate
was ended all these videos emerge of
people celebrating right there's a video
of a flight attendant singing and
dancing with a garbage basket they're
throwing their masks in and I'm like
everybody hated that except for blue
check mark journalists who are like you
should sue Delta if they make you take
your mask off did you if you go in on
the Tweet about the uh so the DC Metro
has taken it off but then um
a buddy of mine who rides it pretty
regularly says they don't really enforce
it anyway he said he was on at once and
um somebody wasn't wearing it and then
someone said something to like the Metro
guy who was on there and said hey this
guy doesn't have his mask on the Metro
guy was like I'm not a cop man what do
you want me to do I said well neither
were the flight attendants right and
also wasn't a law to begin with but if
you go and look at the tweet from the DC
Metro and Marina medvin had posted this
and she was screenshotting all the quote
tweets over the DC Metro were sending
the mask mandate and all they're saying
by the way is it's optional right it's
optional to wear which by the way if you
go to Asia China South Korea Japan mask
wearing if you're sick is pretty normal
it's pretty normalized it's always been
around uh certainly since they dealt
with SARS Navy influence and the other
things but with with this one people
were freaking out and then G Prime had a
really good tweet this morning about it
where he said just imagine if you will
you're mid-flight in a flying coffin
that you could have you could enter the
voice comes over the intercom they start
taking the masks off
the guy who uh tweeted what did he tweet
that I was on applying through mask off
this is Maga air or something
yes and then a journalist reached out
from the New York Times it was like can
you tell me about your experiences like
well it was satire but something only a
journalist would have believed right I
saw that g Prime image of the plan I
didn't know what who it was or what it
was and I thought oh this is some Far
some whacked out journalist that hates
the the mandates were lifted I was like
wow this is trash propaganda and then I
saw the name in my entire perception of
the image changed so at some point maybe
we should put satire above things that
are satires you're starting to sound
like Snopes I thought if his name wasn't
on that I would have thought it was some
some more like somebody that was all
hated the lifting the requests look look
I gotta say you need to be training you
need to be putting on speed these people
will chase you five or six at a time you
might have to run away from them
dreaming if you go anywhere near a Whole
Foods if you go anywhere near a
supermarket airports they congregate in
these spaces Ian I'm telling you they
will swarm and if two or three of them
Scurry away from you right when they see
you unmasked in the aisle
keep up your situational awareness
maintain your guard and your psychic
defenses at all times because they could
be returning with numbers
okay frightening people no I gotta be
honest hold on the G Prime I thought the
G Prime comic was to start he's been on
this kick where he tries to create these
like very intentionally banal left-wing
Comics this whole idea is he's trying to
like get into the head of a New York
Times cartoonist and they're really
funny he does a very good job with
problem I'm having with satire and this
is why I dislike Stephen Colbert for so
long with his old show satire shows that
there's so much lying going on right now
in the universe that I need honesty and
I can't the people that I if the people
I trust start saying things that aren't
true just for an effect I gotta
disengage I can't listen to that stuff
or or respect it interesting let's talk
about CNN my friends we have this story
from axios
CNN plus looks doomed
um where should we get the cake from
yeah you know and when's the party
Sunday Sunday no for real maybe we can
get Chris Wallace to bake it for us all
right here's the story of my friends
from axios they say Warner Brothers
Discovery has suspended all external
marketing spend for CNN plus and has
laid off CNN's longtime Chief Financial
Officer as it weighs what to do with a
subscription streaming service moving
forward now and hold on everybody was
saying that 10 000 subscribers know that
10 000 daily active users axio says they
have 150 000 subscribers so far let me
just put that in some numbers for you if
they're getting between three and six
dollars we're looking at between you
know like what eight around eight
million maybe they're making per month
now they spend I think 250 million to
set it up so they're deep in the hole
and not going to recover that anytime
soon certainly not as much as they
thought it would be but still a lot of
money that being said my friends
if you think we're better than them
please go to timcast.com members because
um we we should have more than that we
don't yes but we should but um we you
know it's it's all a grow it's growth
the more members we get the more people
we hire the bigger we get CNN plus
should not be doing as well as they're
doing they are of course they're still
doing so abysmally bad they're probably
going to get we didn't do you see the
bottom line of that right there sources
say a plan is being considered to
replace Chris Cuomo's 9 pm Eastern prime
time slot with a live new cast and I
love how they describe this newscast
instead of a personality driven
perspective programming wow good yeah
perspective programming yeah you know
you know we we thought about that too
here at timcast we were like why have
this Tim pool guy host a show with
conversation let's just hire Chris Cuomo
and have him you know talk to people
that would make way more I would love to
have Chris Cuomo on if he was like
actually talking yeah yeah you know what
I mean this sounds so Warner Brothers
owns CNN they're just basically pumping
massive amounts of marketing into it to
get 100 000 people to subscribe to their
thing but I mean is that that indicates
nothing to whether or not it's good or
valuable yeah it's not good I'm gonna
sound sorry the issue isn't the 150 000
Subs it's that only 10 000 people on
average use it per day which is like per
day that's 24 hours so think about that
in 24 hours about 400 every hour about
400 people or so or is that is that is
that is that right that's like a that's
like an average telegram chat room you
know kind of thing I mean I I actually
do think I have more people in my
telegram chat actively uh on a regular
basis and that and I know I do not
Market or pay for anything I would like
to see the ratio of other companies that
have subscription models like how many
subscribers timcast has versus how many
people land on it every day same with
Netflix but that's Apple oranges well
you get an idea of the ratio of how many
people actually pay for it and how many
people actually watch it and that's that
number is pretty important yeah I'm I
was do you want to mention this earlier
I'm going to sound like a broken record
here but I still don't understand how
CNN saw that they were doing abysmally
in the ratings and thought you know what
we're going to get people to pay for
this oh yeah why would anyone I mean
like yeah it's like it's free at the
airport that's why people watch it not
anymore yeah they've been at the
airports oh my gosh so that's all right
well maybe that's why they're doing so
far I'll tell you what happened is they
had a meeting and this is my opinion and
went hey why are ratings so bad among
Millennials and some marketing guy was
like because Millennials are watching
streaming services and they were like if
we launch a streaming service we'll get
Millennials I'll tell you I bet the real
issue is that of those 150 subscribers
it's like 149 people who are 55 or older
you know what this is like this is like
quibby you remember quibby yeah that
thing that was around for like five
minutes
so the idea was that it was micro
streaming so they're like hey would it
and they had like the these short Reno
911 episodes those are actually pretty
good but they would only give you a
little bit of it so it was like what do
people love well they love being on
their phones and what else did they love
they love short videos so let's make a
company that's all about
programmed scripted short videos and
deliver it to your phone it was a
complete failure nobody liked it because
that's not organic social media content
right people want either like Live Form
stuff like this not scripted direct
interaction actual human engagement with
you know like actual humans obviously
Ian is you know kind of on a robot
questionable in that sense but um but
you know we accept you as you are and
and it was just an abysmal failure
because again you could that was Jeffrey
katzenberg by the way was behind that um
the former DreamWorks in Disney guy who
you could tell had some meetings and say
like what did the kids like today oh
stream video let's do that but on the
phone it'll be great
the reality was that nobody likes CNN
yes that CNN was like maybe the issue is
that we're not in the right place and
now they're probably you know I hope
they cried I hope someone at CNN is like
sat there and was just like I know that
if we made it what but they really just
don't like us that's a good point Jack
the the modern media now the whole like
one-way media stream is kind of that's
what's dying off it's turning into a
two-way thing if you can't talk to your
subscribers and vice versa then it's no
one wants I actually really I I don't
think that it's just that it's one way
or two way I agree that that could have
something to do with it but it's also
the fact that they're an unreliable
Network they report garbage they don't
have an interesting perspective that
anyone wants to hear that's a good point
because Netflix is one way for the most
part and they're fun you know had an
excellent Netflix is not fine they're
just no flying oh yeah tank today yeah
they tanked massively did anyone figure
out why they're losing subscribers
what's happening they're losing
because they can't afford taxes so
people are cutting their subscriptions
probably oh no no they're probably
moving we'll get to that in a second but
but I I want to throw up a really good
really good text in that kind of
actually uh from a buddy of mine who
children needless right now
um but a guy I used to work with in my
old job if that makes any sense and it
said they had to lift the airline
mandates because it was becoming too
obvious that only La New York City and
the capital city still care about covid
the rest of the country has moved on to
gas prices and food shortages and dot
gov employees are still worried about
the flu their distance from their
subjects has become so far that could
that to convince them that it is still a
democracy they needed to drop the
mandate
democracy
for democracy folks for democracy well I
think the weird thing is to still see
these blue check journalists be like
everyone we should start suing the
airlines right I know for what because
they're like you agreed there would be
masks when I got on this plane and now
you're taking them off and it's like
well that was the government yeah I
looked up um Netflix stock the first
story Netflix loses subscribers tanks
from CNN their new competitor
interesting yeah so what we're talking
about masks something about what we're
going to talk about why you know where
we think the subscribers are going from
Netflix
yeah yeah we're talking about masks so
the bite Administration by the way this
just broke before the uh the um the show
went live the Biden Administration has
announced that right now in a midterm
election year they are actually going to
be fighting to reinstate The Mask
mandates oh yeah federal court so we we
have we we have people who are actively
calling for that's what we're talking
about suing uh Airlines because the mask
mandates got lifted there this is all
come this all comes together you were
mentioning being out of touch with their
subjects right the CNN is on in line
with this narrative on Twitter which
exists among like three percent of the
population that when the masks come off
everyone's screaming and cheering but
CNN is on the side of like this is
really bad you know people should be
upset by this and regular people are
like why would I watch your show I that
does not relate to me who cares well I
don't know I mean I think people not
wearing masks is a threat to our
democracy
we need an unelected bureaucratic doctor
um who's never you know been elected to
dog catcher in his life to be making
decisions for all 315 million Americans
you know someone who you know would be
speckled you know elfish elderly man
that's true democracy is he still around
though that's true because leaving
voicemails yeah if he if he has have you
left any voicemails recently can we give
us an update left some there's a freedom
Tunes video that reported a bunch of
voicemails he left on msnbc's answering
machines yeah that was good the idea
being that fauci is just out of the
media now for some reason that's why
he's gonna come back I'll give the media
that much they recognized fauci's out
and he's not he's like doing the podcast
of the kid who lives next door and stuff
like regular media it's just it's funny
because Tim you sort of mentioned that
it will actually no you mentioned this
that in a midterm election year they're
saying they're going to fight to
reinstate the mandates it is very
bizarre because they've known that
that's a losing issue for a little while
now and everything's going so poorly
it's almost like they're just flailing
around trying to do anything they're not
even thinking strategy when you're that
low in the polls when you're just
sinking you're drowning you're you're
flown they saw that you're not actually
making calculated motions they're like
we've got 33 left how do we destroy the
last speaking of which I guess I forgot
I literally I uploaded a cartoon about
this today you guys check it out it's
called the Democrats brilliant midterm
strategy or the lockdowns are coming
back Philadelphia Philadelphia brought
the mask mandates back yep and we'll see
I said end of last year the man the
lockdowns are going to come back Luke
said they wouldn't it wouldn't happen I
said they would once it started getting
lifted I was like I guess Luke was right
I was wrong but now I'm kind of hearing
that I don't know no I and I I had
reported this and people you know got
all mad at me because they were
discussing this in the white house
um returning the masks or excuse me turn
the lockdowns that they kind of the
impetus for that and then Biden was even
going to do a whole speech about it that
basically got flipped into the
Nationwide vaccine mandate speech but it
was essentially the same type of
rhetoric they just switched it from
lockdowns into vaccines but this whole
idea of you know we're in this together
he keeps they keep talking about it um
Ron Clane the White House Press um or
excuse me the white house chief of staff
keeps referring to this as like his um
you know his FDR moment everything's his
FDR moment right from this to Ukraine to
whatever else he's you know he's the new
FDR he's the new FDR except you can't
get anything past let's talk about Jack
Dorsey and CNN this from the hill Jack
Dorsey says he saw CNN try to create
conflict in Ferguson Timur in Ferguson
yeah and I would I would I would say I
believe Jack Dorsey is right now can I
say I witness whatever it is he sought
no okay what I can say is CNN was there
on the ground and I would describe it as
problematic and it was Jake Tapper right
oh everyone was there oh wow there was
that who's that portly woman in the in
the pink dress
oh no she's not with CNN my bed no no
she's um I can't remember her name but
she's like standing on the street and
then the gunshots start ringing out and
she goes oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh and it's like what are
you doing move people are shooting guns
but no um Don Lemon reported there was
no tear gas while I was getting tear gas
so I'm just like if Jack Dorsey were to
tell me that I'd be like yeah because
when the big news crews came down to
West Florissant I heard one journalist
say something he was he was talking to
someone and then the part of the
conversation I heard was well I'm just
here for networking it's a great
opportunity or something like that wow
because like all like you know I think
Anderson Cooper was there at some point
I'm not sure but uh if if Jack Dorsey
says he saw that I'd be like that's
that's about in line with the with the
uh BS I saw them doing like crappy
reporting no security just flailing all
over the place getting things wrong and
I would not be surprised if they were
trying to egg things on because I've
also seen in other instances of protests
news crews ask protesters to pose for
them that's essentially what he's saying
but then the but then instead of the do
they have the actual phrasing up there
um because I think what he was saying
something about like they asked them to
pose I watched them try to create
conflict and filming it causing the
protesters to chant fcnn so it seems
like it's you know and this is the way
I'm reading it because it's worded kind
of weirdly but it sounds like he's
saying they were trying to pose the
protesters and instead the protesters
turned on CNN
any and this was all in reference to
Brian stelter said Tucker Carlson is
always selling the same thing in
reference to an analytical piece in the
Washington Post that said Fox News was
selling doubt Dorsey responded and you
are all selling hope and then people
were like you're selling the truth Jack
went off like Yeah Tim you you've spent
you know and I mean to pick your brain
about this you know you've spent
obviously uh several hours with Mr
Dorsey on on a famous
um interview slash debate saw that viral
video I sent you that
um this morning were you were Tim asks
uh Vijaya of of the safety and policy of
safety and Trust team on Twitter
um would Twitter allow someone to spread
uh what's considered misinformation I
said would you I I so I could be wrong
but I think it was would you allow
someone to share information about
vaccines that could be wrong and maybe
get someone hurt right and they said
that's not a violation she said that's
not a violation
did not age right years ago the point
being that um you spent all that time
with her and Jack Dorsey so what is your
take on this you know people are calling
it The Dorsey Redemption Arc but I've
been calling it that what do you think a
couple things
um maybe you know Jack said a whole
bunch of really great things when I was
when I when I went there and met with
him I did he was telling me before the
show he was like I want decentralized
immutable social media on the blockchain
and I said whoa that that's beyond what
I'm even talking about dude I'm just
saying don't ban people for saying
naughty words you're saying like
everything you ever post will be forever
and I'm like you started shaming him
you're like that you there needs to be
more regulation on Twitter Jack yeah I
was like wow I'm on the other side of
that one I was like I hear Murray
rothbard yeah I think people should be
allowed to remove it it shouldn't be
permanent but um
afterwards we talked about path to
Redemption never happened and after a
little while I was like all of these
things that Jack keeps talking about he
never does that he could do he won't do
so I don't trust him I don't believe him
he's the CEO what's going on if if he
really believed in it he'd come out and
be like guys here's why it can't be done
here's what I'm struggling with but he
keeps things a secret it could be that
as CEO he was tied up and couldn't make
these moves
I wonder I mean he's a billionaire at
what point does he just feel like I
don't need to be a billionaire dude I
can be a hundred millionaire or a 10
millionaire and I'm gonna tell people
the truth I think he's probably on an
NDA or non-compete Clause of some sort
what's the worst case scenario they
assume to Oblivion what does oblivion
mean I don't know take all his net
wealth away they can't take all of it
away
why would he I don't think he's ready to
make that sacrifice but I know what you
mean but I I don't think he's gonna
that's fine that's fine Jack
it is it is my opinion that Jack
he he tweeted out so much to be said
that can't be said or something of that
effect okay then either he prefers to be
really rich as as opposed to help fix
the problems or he doesn't think telling
the truth would actually do anything of
value so he won't say it anyway so that
that idea that he's talked about before
also in 2019 because I was kind of um uh
tweet-minding his his timeline for stuff
that he said in the past about this and
his idea for decentralizing Twitter was
more than just Twitter itself it was
actually the idea of turning Twitter
into an Internet Protocol and so the
idea being is that and if you remember
the original origin story and I think a
lot of these like Tech origin stories or
kind of like come from a marketing
department as opposed to what's actually
happened but the idea was that it was
supposed to be just sort of this open
group text or an open chat room and that
was the reason for the character limit
so that it was a chat room that you
could share with anybody who had access
and they followed you and they could get
in right
and so the idea being that it was based
off of SMS it was based off of text
message technology so that's obviously
an open protocol so if you have an
Android and I have an iPhone I can text
you you can text me we're across
platforms the idea then for this for a
decentralized protocol based on Twitter
then open source so let's say you have
you know let's say use getter let's say
you use truth let's say whatever like
whatever social media you're using on
this
um there are people who are on it
um that and Twitter that you would be
able to interact with people across the
platforms that I could see those posts
if I followed that person even if they
weren't expressly on my platform yeah
that's what we're building with our
charity well the charity that we're
getting revved up at the moment that's
completely the future of the internet I
think Jax wanted it becomes a protocol
and you can't yeah you can yeah it's a
piece of software that no one controls
it's just a decentralized software unit
it's just like inverted email imagine
you'd go to the Firehouse the feed
whatever right and anyone can host it
your account is your own website so
people wouldn't follow you know at
timcast they would follow you know at
timcast.com or whatever and then all of
my tweets and videos are on my own
website but if you're following on the
decentralized app you can see those
things I think that's the future because
then no one can ban you you're just in
you're just there on the internet and
people can subscribe kind of like RSS
all we got to do is
is build it no it it's exactly like RSS
yeah RSS 3.0 it was that was the
beginning of the idea it's becoming
different with what we're working on
with everybody
um and I'm not ready to announce exactly
what it is yet but it's it's very very
close to it now so he teed up something
uh Dorsey in a recent tweet
um that they do have a project it's
called like blue sky I think it's been
out for a while and
um
this is the thing I've dm'd with them so
often you know over the years like not
all the time but enough talking about
stuff like this that I just I was like
this dude's just lying because he's
gonna say these things publicly and he's
like we're working on Blue Sky and then
nothing happens it's remarkable because
which sounds great they all sound great
dude if I if I had
one tenth of Jack dorsey's wealth it'd
be done
it would be it would you'd have an alpha
in a few months well you need developers
even even yeah I mean everybody's
looking billions of dollars money isn't
a developer you need to find the people
that do it dude come on if I and then
you gotta find people that like each
other that want to work together that's
true but if you had 20 million dollars
to spend on the project it would it
would be an alpha within come on man you
could throw a lot of money at a group of
people and get nothing dude it's been
three years it's all about it's been a
year but what they need is organization
I know people with lots of money they
need people to organize and do it
right if you are worth 20 million
dollars
you can do it Ian are you extending your
services to Jack Dorsey I'm doing it for
free baby
join us Jack it's it's it's like
you know we're trying to set up a
non-profit that has no money to get this
going and it's taking forever to get the
filings but it's been like six months
and there's people already working on it
so I don't know if they're doing in Blue
Sky but three years on I'm like Jack I
really don't believe you're working on
this I wonder what he's doing yeah it's
it's it's Whispering sweet nothing's
Interiors you wanna know what he's doing
here's what people are saying Elon Musk
might take over Twitter all of a sudden
Jack Dorsey comes out as this Rogue
figure who's like I've had enough it's
time to be honest and tell the truth and
now people on the right are going to be
like yeah you go Jack and then Jack's
like we don't need Elon I'm here and
then once Elon gets pushed out Elon
Jack's gonna be like okay so let's um
start censoring everybody again and if
we need to sponsor everyone on Twitter
all the time you're not being censored
you gotta do that I wasn't I wasn't
looking at you when you started that and
I thought that was Jackson he was
actually sitting in the other chair the
whole time and we just didn't know how
did I miss the nose ring
but I've asked Jack to come on a couple
times he always says like yes at some
point he's busy
I'd love to actually have him talk about
these things the issue is Now's the Time
the first time he went on Joe Rogan Joe
had a huge backlash he got all these
thumbs down because Jack was just saying
garbage nonsense and then they didn't
actually get to the core of the issues
then when I go on with Jack Vijaya and
Joe they didn't I I they did not expect
to get these questions that I had for
them because they probably assumed it
was going to be like some right-wing
dude just being like why'd you be on
Milo and instead we had like
philosophical questions about you know
the ethics of the rules and the World
Views and things like this all the
things they said they're just spinning
they're spinning a tail yeah I think
he's because he's on the board he has
like a decant disparage to company so he
can't really say a fiduciary duty yeah
yeah right well we were talking about
this earlier in the show but he likes
being a billionaire goes into it goes
into what Tim you were saying a second
ago which is that as soon as somebody on
the left who has been our enemy for
virtually their entire time in public
life says something remotely sensible we
go yes this person is speaking to truly
love I mean look when someone says
something that's true we should
absolutely celebrate the fact that
they've they've said something true but
you can't just start looking up to these
people as Heroes they've really got to
earn it by showing results unfortunately
he hasn't he said I think at one point
that he realizes now that he was part of
the problem of creating big Tech he was
like you know he really wanted a free
speech Network and he did it but he
didn't you know he made some pitfalls
like with Chris pavlovski are out there
like what pitfalls to avoid he went
public that's a pitfall be careful he
made his code private be careful that's
a pitfall because then people can
control it when you're no longer there
and you don't have access to it anymore
so he's made those mistakes and I think
the great thing about Jack is he's like
been through the gauntlet and he that'd
be why he's a great interview well this
is the this is the theory that he's you
know this is like Dr Frankenstein and
Frankenstein's monster right you know I
want to create life I want to help
people but instead of create this thing
that ends up causing more harm than good
yeah no I'm I am not saying anything
about Dorsey what he's done whether he
is uh you know I I just want to make
assumptions in good faith and say he
does mean what he's saying unless it's
proven otherwise but conservatives can't
jump on the he's great horse right
without seeing some actual results I'll
throw this out there you know I I love
Twitter right I'm coming up on it'll be
10 years that I've been on Twitter next
month and it is it is clearly the the
simplest most efficient mass
communication system that's ever been
invented in the history of mankind right
and Jack Dorsey was part of that so like
everything else I'll start I'll always
start with that he's made me realize
I've been on Twitter for I think 13
years yeah 13 years like I just wanted
to go back to the way it was without all
this exercise that's it that's literally
it when it was the Free Speech well it
seemed nice but it was still proprietary
they were still spying on you it always
seems nice in the beginning and then
they start yeah but you but Alex Jones
was there and he was funny
well Jones never actually posted himself
that was always staff but I just mean
like his videos his videos were there
yeah but yeah and if you didn't like it
you couldn't follow it yeah you block
him or block now it becomes a great
function yeah
you want to know what all that Twitter
really is to me is I follow news
organizations journalists and
personalities and so I'll see like
Reuters tweet something and then when I
retweet a news story this is usually in
the past month or so it's just like
reminding myself of the story right so I
can go back and look for it later I
don't care to interact for the most part
I will sometimes or I'll just post
garbled nonsense because it's hilarious
how triggered and riled up everybody get
like uh gets I tweeted schools should
have religious studies because you know
great schools because kids have
questions and teachers should give
answers and the teachers should tell the
students to keep it a secret from their
parents like I just like posting things
like that
so the importance though of Twitter is
because it it serves as a narrative
bottleneck
um particularly for the West
um you can see this most predominantly
right now with the war in Ukraine that
the opinion makers and the opinion
making it all starts on Twitter so then
that filters down to whether it be CNN
plus whether it be Netflix there's been
um examples of TV shows that were saved
just because they had great you know
Twitter followings
um and from a geopolitical geostrategic
standpoint we've seen that so much of
this comes off of Twitter
um meanwhile you know to use Ukraine as
an example because so much stuff gets
censored if you're on telegram it's like
you're watching a completely different
narrative because it's unfiltered on
there no obviously sure there's going to
be bad actors on both sides but telegram
is uncensored and it's very heavily
focused on that whereas Twitter is
heavily censored or Twitter is heavily
censored and you're getting a completely
different narrative there let's let's uh
let's jump back to Netflix we have the
story from CNBC Netflix shares crater 25
after company reports it lost
subscribers for the first time in more
than 10 years get woke go broke
that's it Netflix I mean they've done
some things that are good but I think
the narrative the machine it's it's
fumbling it's bumbling it's falling
apart regular people are tuning into
shows like this the media landscape is
heavily diversifying people are sick and
tired of the machine they want something
real and authentic isn't it interesting
how poorly tech companies seem to be
aging over the past 10 or 20 years I
mean everyone everyone says I loved
Netflix when it first started now it's
absolutely awful same with Facebook same
with Twitter basically every social
media company it's because the CIA is my
guess is that intelligence agencies are
are webbed in with these things and
making them do stuff and give
information away and and spying and when
the codes aren't the algorithms aren't
free so copy left licenses like agpl3
you have no way of verifying that these
people if they may look like yeah but
our stream is working I still see the
chat too yeah chat's working internet's
working everything's working but the
show's uh I'm getting a message that we
may have to switch over to a different
network
I don't know if that matters um
but uh we will try
so the the issue is that our internet is
working the stream is going up but
YouTube is not putting the show out guys
we're just gonna have to talk and chat
that this was it was the breaking point
I was like thank you
yeah we have no other networks available
they're working on it right now
of course wait I've got it
yeah it's gonna it's gonna freeze on me
oh wait yeah yeah there's a delay yep
freezes on Ian making the okay signs
moment I touched my finger to my thumb
they're like look at this you know
honestly I thought this is I think it
was inevitable oh we're back on oh the
stream is back what's up everybody did
they switch the network no that's that's
live because that's me holding the phone
right I believe we're back give us a one
in chat if you can hear us wait this is
this is weird because I'm watching we
are back I'm actually watching wait
infinity infinity
conspiracy theorists hey everybody sorry
about that blip but how many frames did
it drop
when I was talking about DuckTales in
the old episode about the a certain uh
red and blue flag with an X that was
carried by a gray uniformed Army
don't say naughty words I know let me
just I just say for everybody who's
listening
um smash the like button yes subscribe
to timcast.com the full version and the
weird minute or so I think it was like
two minutes that dropped off we'll be in
the podcast version but uh our internet
didn't go out our internet didn't go out
we were I was I I don't know if you guys
saw me post in the chat everything was
working but on YouTube's end something
was not going through now this has
happened in the past where we've been
talking about something and
um related to China and we've had weird
YouTube drop us off we are the age of
cyber war is upon us you never know
who's who's got effective you know
fingers in the pot if you can hear me
Smash the like button everyone it's the
only way we'll know let us know we need
to know is anybody out there is the like
button even like just do anything just
to finish the story for for my own
autistic purposes
um that that episode of DuckTales on
Disney plus was removed okay which one
was it again because I'm about the
Confederacy right
we were at a gas station and there was
like the gas station sell the
Confederate flags and they called the
rebel flag right and there's like it's
just like funny seeing like a little
girl holding it up smiling like in the
bag just because of the way the left
frames it and the way they freak out but
like when you go to Tennessee or in
southern states it's like totally normal
and not even that big of a deal to
anybody there yeah we saw one flying on
a hill on the way back from tennis
it's happening that's wild I want to
take a moment to really appreciate the
technology that we have right now this
amazing streaming technology cameras
microphones the ability to communicate
across the world in the blink of an eye
with someone from their home because
like you can see just because we have it
now doesn't mean we're always going to
or that we always may take advantage of
it while you have it yeah I mean yeah
don't don't take it for granted that's
for sure yeah yeah I agree we can unify
a lot of people I was thinking about
Hitler and how he was obsessed with
unification so we got to unify correctly
and I think the why the founding fathers
had it right because it was a group of
them doing it together it wasn't one
person I just noticed that we got a ton
of people smashing the like button so I
should I should I should do better I
can't tell if you can hear me uh become
a member at timcast.com if you can hear
me it's the only way we'll know
um like people actually did Smash the
like button thank you so much uh what
sorry what were you saying oh we're
right on the verge of doing something
really great for society if we work
together I I think it's easy to grow a
cult group of people like as a YouTuber
for yourself but you gotta remember the
dictatorship type thing doesn't work if
we're going to use this technology for
good we got to do it together speaking
of a Cults YouTubers did we play the uh
which one Mr no advertisers oh oh my God
this is nuts so good yeah yeah so sad
yeah wow
we'll base our freedom around a
constitution not around people yes
United States is not a democracy so
ladies and gentlemen it is with the uh
utmost
um remorse and respect that we mentioned
Ethan Klein of the H3 podcast announced
is this clip from today I believe so in
in a clip that was posted today he has
no sponsors because he is an existential
threat to gay people in his own words I
believe in his own words I would like to
play for you this clip from the H3 from
the H3 TV uh video here we go
I'll just say this let me fix the audio
very thankful to our members
it makes this show kind of uh
bulletproof no sorry Gary stands here we
go
today we have no sponsors because uh
uh I am an existential threat to uh gay
rights
and all progress
so of course our wonderful uh fans have
taken upon themselves to write all of
our sponsors
and um to have them uh
can't uh not sponsor or not to support
us so
we are
um
I'm very you know
I'll just say this it's a I'm very
thankful to our members it makes this
show kind of uh
bulletproof to stuff like this even
though it's painful and emotionally it
just doesn't it's just painful that you
know people would do that
okay I want to say a few things
um first Ethan is correct about members
and that's why we said we I wish we set
up the website years ago but you you
learn when you learn and had I known
what I know now I would have been like
that was that should have been the first
thing we did because once they started I
mean the censorship was a big problem
for a while we had videos taken down
that's why we we dedicated to this I
will say that um you know Ethan mentions
in the clip
you expect more from the sponsors and uh
he's right he's right about that too you
do you do but um I will also add I
genuinely do feel bad for Ethan I think
he doesn't understand what he's involved
in I think he didn't he doesn't know
what the world's become I think he's
genuinely been lost this whole time so
let's go back in time to January when
Ethan Klein deleted episodes with with
he had with Jordan Peterson
he clearly did this because he was
panicking about getting canceled he
doesn't want his business to fall apart
so he's just like okay fine dude I'll do
whatever I have to Ethan you should have
just stood by your principles which is
edgy comedy free speech and having
conversations with people
we have never had one of our show
sponsors cancel on us pull out on us in
fact the first sponsor that I had ever
had on YouTube virtual Shield sponsors
us to this day no issues despite all the
controversies the lies the smears the
manipulation and I will stand by what we
believe in and what we say and I'm not
going to play these stupid games
Ethan started playing the games getting
scared panicking
he chose to get into business business
with these companies and now he is
sitting there saying it sucks I have no
sponsor well look man you gotta stand up
for yourself you can't let these people
push you around you should not have
taken down the Jordan Peterson episode
because you look duplicitous you look
like you're lying and you look desperate
and so I hope it works out but hey man I
can only say if you want to get in bed
with people who will Who will uh push
you off that metaphorical uh
Cliff at any moment
well then I can only say like you should
have you should have prepared for this
you should have expected it you knew it
was going to happen if imagine this
imagine if Ethan Klein instead of
deleting the Jordan Peterson episode
came out and said
they're telling me if I don't delete
this episode they're going to pull my
sponsors pull them I will not take down
the conversation with Dr Peterson
imagine how much you'd be supported oh
you get 100 000 more followers that
subscribe to his network
is I hate to say I Told You So Ian if
you hit Justin bodied the archetypal
hero oh my goodness I've been sitting
across from this fella for too long
apologize for that error I hate to say I
Told You So Ethan if he here's what he
did he said to the people who try to
threaten you by having your sponsors
taken that he will comply he said yes if
you are somebody who is sponsoring my
work I will dilute my message and walk
back things I've said in the past once
you've told me not to you're inviting
control at that point and also
I want to point out that when you
cultivate a fan base full of people who
would cancel someone guess what happens
to you eventually you get canceled it's
not that complicated
if if uh I feel like this is a guy who
got started doing edgy comedy on Reddit
and YouTube yes things like that and
then as times went on he thought I just
better say what they're saying the
problem is once again this is not
mainstream America he is bending the
knee to Weirdos Jordan Peterson is
popular among regular people the people
who don't like him are The Fringe
weirdos regular people do like him
So when you say I'm going to take it
down because he's a bad guy you got
tricked Ethan Klein got tricked and now
what's he gonna do you know I'm seeing
everyone on the right mock him and and
they're laughing about it Jordan
Peterson told him that eventually he'd
be held to a standard uh by the very mob
he wishes he currently wishes to please
then you will make a mistake and they
will devour you with Glee please take
this warning seriously I liked you Ethan
should not have sided with those seeking
destroy he should have sided with those
seeking to protect and to develop
because if he came out and said I like
talking Dr Peterson on more than one
occasion I may not agree with everything
he has to say but we have to defend our
right to say these things then they'd be
like we're going to harass your sponsors
and he'd be like okay and then people on
the right would be like we got sponsors
for you buddy don't worry we appreciate
you standing by your principles and
doing your thing but too too much Ethan
has been drifting into just saying
whatever the left wants and and look at
what happens you know he did that thing
with Hassan
you want you want you want to live with
people like you want to work with people
who will destroy you in two seconds by
all means you go ahead and do it but I
don't know I don't know what I can do
for you when your life is destroyed by
these very people we can supply
technology that you can use Ethan in the
future for direct subscription content
so you can bypass like patreon and crap
like that take control of your network
we'll do it we'll work together man I
like you I am real quick on the the
issue with our stream
um I'll get every message I'm getting in
is people saying that the minute it
stopped was right when Ian started
talking about Intel collection via
social media yeah it's hard to tell I
said even it was like the CIA but
there's no way yeah
shut them down yeah and then it just
immediately stops and someone I think
may have pointed out foreign networks as
well because what I'm talking
intelligence is it doesn't have to be an
American wait okay well you just said it
again okay but but but and he should be
to be fair
um
you know Ethan Klein he gets canceled by
the left and was his sponsors we call
out the CIA and then our stream just
freezes in Midstream so right you know
you got to choose the American
government we are the good guys I'm even
down with secret agents look you need
what you need to do is obviously because
he's now a free agent apparently because
Malcolm Nance is no longer working for
MSNBC you need to sign him up as a
special foreign correspondent for
timcast for timcast IRL would you sign
Malcolm Nance no
but why because racism is he's a bad
person did he actually go to war is that
what happened he wasn't he was an
intelligence officer but he's not an
intelligent officer he was never in a
naval intelligence officer he never a
naval intelligence officer Wikipedia
says he was he was a Navy Chief which is
not an officer and he was a linguist
he's not he was that is not the same
thing Wikipedia was wrong oh my God no
uh he he's he's got a picture of himself
like he's in Ukraine with like tactical
gear you saw the video right yeah where
he's like looking at his watch and he's
like the missiles they're coming it's
South Southwest stand by Stand By and
he's like he's like one of my dad
everyone else is just sitting there like
dude everyone's like walking around the
background my dad you know when we were
little he used to you know you know when
you hear the the lightning and thunder
and you can you know count how many
seconds between the flash that's like
one one thousand two one thousand and
then but Nance is doing that for
missiles they're flying over that's a
cruise anti-ship missile it's coming
from a ship
towards us now and everyone's like okay
dude like you're you're fine like like
it's yeah we know like we're aware uh
I'll talk to you guys about twisting
Universe you time to go on that yeah
we should talk about
um Ethan having him on the show well
Ethan's welcome on the show but I don't
think he'd do it because
they never want to actually there's a
lefty guy who's tweeting he's dming me
right now like why why aren't I on the
show here's the issue with with the left
as we often bring this up prominent left
personalities always have an excuse as
to why they won't come and do a show
yeah um it's always Ben Shapiro yelling
debate me or at least the meme right but
when it comes to the left they're like
I'm not going on your show or they'll
publicly be like I'll go on a show I can
do it yeah so your whole thing with uh
Hassan the other day yeah because uh he
said he would come out and come on the
show but then he dm'd me and he was like
hey bro like covid I'm you know I'm
pretty scared of kovid so I don't want
to do it and I said I get it man that
was that was the the first time that was
the first time right and then this time
he got mad because uh Hassan tweeted a
joke David Pacman said do you know
anybody who's pro-abortion I uh Hassan
then said me I'm trying to do this David
Beckman said that sounds weird someone
said what's wrong with more abortions I
screen grabbed that and posted with no
comment I thought it was funny I thought
the whole interaction was funny no
comment and Hassan responds with dude
it's a joke man do you need me to put
slash S and I'm like I didn't say it
wasn't a joke I literally just reposted
what you did right so then he made a
tweet about how you know me and Dave
Rubin or whatever and then he I was like
we claim to claim to be progressives or
true progressives and or or like were
people who are rallying people who
claiming to be true progressives and I
was like I've never said I was a
progressive I am not a progressive I am
a Centrist moderate and he was like
you're literally doing what I'm making
fun of you for and I'm like dude I was
like that's not an argument you're
welcome to come on the show and give a
conversation then and then all of a
sudden I'm not coming on your show I I
won't do it and then I was like oh here
we go here we go
you know so we got a guy who wants to
come in the show right he was saying
because you're another part of the
country and the travel and cut into my
Twitch streaming but you know he agreed
to do it before and kovid was the reason
and now it's oh I'm too busy and I'm
like dude I can respect if you're busy
it's hard for me to travel to go to
people's shows I still bought a trailer
we drove down to Nashville and I went on
a bunch I went on Candace's show on The
Daily wire I went on their Sports show
and I went on Backstage Live I will make
that happen and so I was like dude I'll
get the trailer we'll bring it to La
it'll be really difficult but we'll
figure that out spend a week in La maybe
I don't really want to how's the drive
to Nashville by the way oh it's fun it
was nine nine that looks that'd be nice
my Blues Traveler a few times by purple
circle good guitar amazing guitar and
one of the best songs I've heard in a
while uh by Nickelback the Devil Went
Down to Georgia and I am being
completely serious I cannot believe that
was actually Nickelback he actually put
it on before the the episode and it was
it and I I I was saying this live
it's good Nickelback's good you
here's what the ratio is we've got
somebody on the left they're like the
people who want to come on the show that
are on the left have like no followers
they're not particularly prominent
individuals they're I get I get messages
from people who are like I'd love to
come on the show and I'm like dude I'm
not saying you shouldn't come on the
show just because you have no followers
because we that's not the prerequisite
for being on the show but it's the body
of work and typically there's a
correlation between someone with you
know uh who's not particularly prominent
and a limited body of work for which we
can actually comment on and then what
happens is you bring on someone who is a
limited body of work in a low following
count and when you end up destroying
them in a debate the left then says the
only thing you could do is bring on this
guy who's like not even that good
because he couldn't get a real debate
and it's just like
I got no problem we'll have we'll have
we we've got a few people come on you've
had people come on that only have a few
thousand followers because followers is
not the reason we've had people come on
with no with no social media and things
like that I'm just referring to body of
work and you let Ian come on yeah all
right of course yeah you know the first
time I was ever invited I really had to
have a long debate with myself about
whether I wanted to platform Tim I was
like am I promoting this I know right I
got a feeling that a lot of people are
afraid that if they come talk to you
that you'll bring up like information
and over like just destroy them with
like not destroy but fact take them to
town with information and facts and then
they'll feel like an idiot and look
humiliated when in fact they can just
come hang out and just like learn but
the problem is like do you guys remember
when Hunter Avalon was on the show
yeah yeah he tried challenging me on the
Ukraine story with Biden and I'm like I
was like wow you're really gonna was
this one he was trying so he because he
like got big as as like a conservative
and then he tried to like Veer really
hard to the left and this was after he
was already now but he was like I
mentioned the Joe Biden you know well
SOB I got fired he's like that didn't
happen and I was like yeah he's like no
I didn't and I'm like here's the video
and then I'm like bro don't come here
having done no research but acting like
you know these stories I've dug in and
done so much journalism on this stuff
the problem is with people like him and
uh is that he sees memes and thinks Tim
pool has no idea what he's talking about
just repeats right wing talking points
when literally all day this morning I
was digging into the The Washington Post
story looking at public records and
doing legit hours of like real research
and journalism I make phone calls I do
the work it is it is rough Mayo gate I
love the story actually called the
restaurant I call for comment we do this
all the time I reached out to Taylor
rents for comment I reached out to the
Washington Post for comment our Newsroom
did at this stuff we do the research
these people see these memes and these
meme clips and they're like the right
silly talking points Dude shows up here
and says Joe Biden never said that I was
like are you kidding bro did you even
Google it here's the video and I played
it and he's like oh that really happened
and then I'm like let's talk about my
clothes my clothes let's talk about the
formation of barisma let's talk about
the former CIA CIA guy who's working on
there let's talk about gas problem dude
you do not want to get involved with me
I was in Ukraine I went there I watched
those protests happen I'm not going to
pretend to be the expert of all experts
on this stuff but man for these people
living on the internet doing no research
then they finally come here and it is
like getting hit slammed by a tidal wave
where it's like oh wow boy do they look
bad and the problem is for many of these
people is they want to maintain this
facade of I'm on the left well what
happens when they come and sit down with
Steve Bannon and Steve Bannon goes text
the rich and they go I agree Steve
Banner yeah and then all everyone on the
left is like they were agreeing with
Steve Bannon there you go that's one of
the big problems I know the last left
does not like you know what you know I
think is good Destiny was it Stephen
Bonnell III because that guy has no
problem telling it exactly how he thinks
he's not gonna do it once though and
that's fine but because he he accused me
of not of lying about being in the
military I'm lying about being in the IC
and I did not take that well when when
he came on the show he has no problem
and it didn't go over he knows the
stories he knows what he thinks about
him we just disagree and I'm like I can
respect that but there are there are
many people where they think they're
going to come on this show and they're
going to be like you're you think this
about race and I'm like no I agree with
you on systemic racism and they're like
you do and I'm like yeah do you watch
this show and they're like no but I saw
memes once so this is one of the reasons
I think they really do not want to come
on the show Hassan will come on the show
you know the last thing I said about
Hassan before that tweet thread was that
he was right there was a story that came
out I can't remember exactly what it was
it was months ago and I was like he was
Julian Assange I think I defended him
because people were ragging on him about
Julian Assange and I was like Hassan did
not like was make a joke about a son she
did not literally say this and I'm like
it's silly we don't need to go after him
blah blah blah just because and then the
dude gets mad at me because he doesn't
actually watch the show if Hassan came
on this show he'd be like what about
this and I'd be like I agree and Ian
would be like I agree and James would be
like yeah actually I I agree with with
the details of that I made his Grand
policy and then what's he gonna say
what's he gonna argue about all of a
sudden the narrative is going to be
Hassan goes on timcast and agrees with
everything they're saying he must be far
right yeah just talk about your past man
let's learn about where it got you to
video streaming and into it you used to
work for The Young Turks like what's
your relationship with chank when you
guys are young you know that kind of
stuff let's just let's just show humans
that we can interoperate and still have
differing views I tweeted at him he was
like why can't I go on zoom and I was
like we don't do Zoom internet makes us
hate each other it's better to sit down
shake hands and talk about it and that's
why we do it the way we do Andy no hit
me up and he's like can I do your show
remote and I said sorry dude can't do it
then he came here Lauren Southern can I
come on your show remote I said we don't
do remote you can't even do it in person
Lauren like we don't want to see you
around here yeah and well uh even for
Andy know and Lauren Southern I was like
what about Snowden
I I don't want to do it I really do not
want to do it I I remember watching Joe
Rogan's episodes where he did zoom and I
was like not fun yeah episode is 30
million views because it's snowed that's
that yeah I don't do this for 30 million
views like I want to sit down with
people and talk and even when we have so
would you go to Russia to interview
Snowden the problem assuming you know
travel was was fine and all oh two
seconds yeah the the real issue is that
I can't run a business while flying to
Russia you know what I mean yeah we're
trying to get to that point exactly what
you mean why are you scared of debating
Snowden so you won't debate Snowden then
you're terrified I would I would love to
debate Snowden and say that you
published documents without going
through them and redacting critical
information and that was a serious
intelligence risk I don't view uh what's
known as a whistleblower view him as a
leaker because he did not actually
review the documents that he was giving
away uh and he's admitted to that I can
respect that he admitted to it I think
the distinction is important he did
expose a bunch of really important
things that's fantastic but I think
terminology is important in
understanding what someone did someone
who sees malfeasance and says hey you
guys got to know about this
whistleblower someone who says I see a
bad stuff I'm gonna take all of it and
just give it to journalists I'm like
leaker different thing you know he did
blow the whistle technically what about
Manning then Manning was a whistleblower
collateral murder that was incredible
but but didn't Manning still grab a
bunch of doctors there were a bunch of
documents yes if it depends I don't know
exactly I'd have to research the Manning
stuff the issue with Snowden was that
Snowden has admitted to being like I
didn't read this and it's like okay well
then you're just leaking stuff that you
don't actually know what you're putting
out there and I think it was actually it
might have been John Oliver who was like
in the documents You released there was
unredacted critical information that put
people at risk and he was like I didn't
check or I was no he was like uh it was
published by the journalists they failed
to redact and he was like I didn't I
didn't know and he's like shouldn't you
have to like is that your responsibility
and I was like yeah that is I guess so I
can respect that you know but uh we got
a few minutes you wanted to mention that
the universe is twisting out of control
yeah well it's definitely interesting
under control apparently uh there's this
theory that the universe is expanding
and a big part of that is because when
they look far far out into the universe
beyond the Galaxy they see what's called
a red shift it looks like the stuff
that's further away the the wavelengths
of light are getting getting longer so I
started to think about wavelength and I
brought this little prop and I'm sorry
if you're not watching the video you're
gonna have to get a hold of one of the
videos so you can watch this part and
get an idea but maybe you can imagine
along with me look at this look at this
wavelength now imagine it's on a flat
plane it's gonna look like a very short
wavelength like it's very short if this
wavelength turns sideways the wavelength
itself becomes longer it's the same way
if you're just looking at it from a
different angle so it will attempt it
will begin to appear red as it's turning
and then I start thinking of the Taurus
and how maybe we're on like a donut like
on the Taurus twisting around itself
seeing the outside of the Universe from
a different angle so we see the light
reflecting then I started thinking about
the singularity at the center of every
black hole and every Taurus toroidal
black hole perhaps and uh
the big bang and I think what's
happening is as we're twisting around
once we twist back through the center we
have what we consider the Big Crunch and
then when we come out the other side of
the center it expands open into what we
might think is the Big Bang
so tweeted about it you can follow along
oh there's and posted this image of the
donut universe so um Ian believes the
universe is both Hollow and flat and I'm
not saying that the universe is not
expanding it might still be expanding
it's just the main piece of evidence for
the expansion is the redshift and if
this also explains the redshift then
um then you could argue that you may
want to remove that evidence as part of
the expansion Ian is effectively arguing
for solid state Theory just a little
different version of it solid state
theory was like before the Big Bang they
believe the universe just was and it was
like you know yeah and then this would
be a black hole that we're inside of
that's inside of another universe that's
also a black hole ever fractally uh
expansion I believe Hawking had a theory
as well about uh multiple big bangs and
that so it was which it kind of lines up
with what you're saying like it just
keeps happening yeah I don't know about
it that it how does that explain the big
values well that once you're twisting
around back and through the center you
experience The Singularity or the Big
Crunch where everything comes together
for a moment and then expands back out
again so it folds in on itself if you're
in the inside and then coming out the
other side it looks like it's exploding
like blasting out right so actually I
would I would say you're twisting
universe theory is it you have a
three-dimensional representation of a
twisting universe but perhaps it's
actually a multi it's beyond three
dimensions oh yeah yeah the universe is
yeah this is a three-dimensional way to
look at it but I think Ian you you
should read about M Theory and string
theory yeah Eric Weinstein particularly
has a geometrical Unity uh theory that
and he talks a lot about that the
universe is also a Taurus and Nasim
Harriman talks about uh the universe in
the source child proton paper how it's
equal density and which made no sense
because it was expanding so with this
Theory uh this could explain why there's
equal density but I got it I gotta say
I've read a little bit about M Theory a
while ago and it looks like this is a
rudimentary concept interesting yeah
like if you actually write M Theory
you'd be like oh this is a few steps
before where we're actually one thing I
keep finding with science is that
there's so many ways to explain
something you can explain it
two-dimensionally three-dimensionally
four-dimensionally five and they're all
right they're all different ways like
the electric universe is real gravity is
real but they're just different ways of
looking at the force
what's amazing to me is that so and
Seamus you probably know about this too
so Isaac Newton right and we we credit
him and and I was on the war room
um we talked about this a little bit on
the Easter special that Newton was you
know he's basically credited for like
obviously being one of the smartest guys
that ever lived
um you know arguably you know developed
calculus
um at least independently
um master of Cambridge for years and
years but he didn't even consider
himself a mathematician he thought that
was just like a side gig and what he
really focused on was theology the Bible
uh secrets of the universe
um they call it Alchemy and occult
thinking but what he really was
interested in what I mean this idea of
codes in the Bible codes in the pyramids
digging millions and millions of words
that he wrote about this after he left
Cambridge that people just totally
dismissed when you were talking about
Jesus dying and then going through hell
before he ascended to Heaven it made me
think of the Taurus and going through
the center of the singularity
experiencing hell to be rebirthed oh
yeah we were talking about that a little
bit prior to the time maybe we can do
that in the after show we'll talk more
about that we get it we get that if you
want but that's that's the theory the
layers of hell um Tim you brought up a
cool graphic so what's this String
Theory tell me about it it's String
Theory so this is this is I'm not a
physicist M Theory also uh I think M
Theory is an advanced version of it but
I'm not a physicist I read one book a
long time ago but the the general idea
is the universe is like a series of
membranes that are folding so it could
be a bunch of Tauruses all like you know
like this thing behind me where is it
over here
it's like a bunch of Tauruses all
layered on top of each other like maybe
64 of them and then you get a shape like
that
could be something perhaps that's like
in motion but we just took a snapshot of
it or the Earth is both Hollow and flat
down at Earth theory tell me more well
you know I was reading these people
saying that the Earth was Hollow and I
was like interesting but then I saw the
people saying the Earth was flat and I'm
like why not both
that's a more fun theory in my opinion
donut Earth what is inside the donut
Earth jelly
so it's full of Taylor Larez
um they're probably gigantic Caverns
underground which may have huge rivers
and oceans and and like plant like
fungus that grows and glows like
iridescent light and animals we've never
seen before what if it turned out that
like the surface world is the North
Korea of Earth and that you know deep
underground are Advanced civilizations
of humans and then we're just living in
this dictatorship where they don't let
us go to the North Pole to go into the
hole into the into Hollow Earth oh and
they're controlling us through the elf
band The extremely low frequency which
is another interesting the elf band of
radiation the extremely low frequency
band and Michael Mouse talks about DMT
and seeing elves when you see this elf
band of frequency that is apparently
interconnecting the human consciousness
maybe they're affecting it from
underground maybe a joke but how about
we affect super chats so if you haven't
already smash that like button become uh
become members at timcast.com if you
want to watch the members only show
coming up and uh become a member in
general just to support the work our
journalists do because I gotta say 9 90
plus percent of what you'll get from
timcast.com is just the journalism that
we put out and it is only possible
because we have members so that is the
true value of the site because if we got
to the point where we had like 200 000
members then you would be seeing our
articles everywhere we want to get to
the point where breaking news doesn't
come from fake news manipulators and
Liars who docks it comes from real
journalists and that's what we're
working on so don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the share with your friends and
let's read some super chats
Gerald Armstrong says Tim we need to
spread the word and find out what
happened to Gonzalo lira what happened
to Gonzalo Lira well from what I can
tell he was in Ukraine documenting the
war um The Daily Beast did an article
about him and took a lot of stuff out of
context from what I could see he was a
Pua guy at first Pua pickup artist yeah
he was a pickup artist like a YouTuber
and like he's not even particularly like
political prior to that either he said
some wrong thing I mean when your
country's at War if you start talking
out against your country I imagine
they're gonna but I don't have an enemy
no I don't think he's Ukrainian though
no he's an American in Ukraine but he
was in Ukraine I think I think he's born
in Chile actually so Chilean but has
American citizenship but somehow ends up
I you know I don't know the whole
details there yeah but he's in but he
was in I believe it was harkiv in um in
Ukraine posting videos I I saw one of
his videos it was you know it was fun
didn't find anything threatening by his
video or anything like that I mean he
was just posting basically his theories
about some stuff that was going on in
the media from the quotes I saw from
Daily Beast it made him look like a
Putin apologist and that he thought
Russia was in the right it was kind of
framing it like that and then also he
disappeared now no one knows where he is
well so he had a tweet up that went
hyper viral and he said if you want to
know the truth about Ukraine uh look up
these and I think it was like seven
names of various figures and oligarchs
throughout Ukraine and then he said
something to the extent of if you don't
hear from me in 12 hours you know this
will be the last my last tweet or
something and then and then he actually
disappeared after that wow
all right let's read more we got sorta
Who says let's talk more chickens that's
right chicken city is uh up and running
and one of the most successful super
chatted live streams in the world no
joke no joke
um yeah seriously I think after we get a
few months of chicken City up and
running you'll see it up here in the top
rankings but based on the current trend
of averaging I think we're averaging
around like twelve hundred dollars a day
one day we had like 15 one day we had
like nine then we had like 12. so people
really do enjoy feeding chickens
the king of the chickens yeah he's gonna
be retiring soon though oh right because
Sarah had a son so he's a Brahma and
he's going to be really big his big
rooster and so we want you know those
big rooster jeans want to make the
chickens all bigger so we're going to be
you know he's gonna take over
Roberto Jr will be in charge for a while
Roberto was going to go retire at the
boys dormitory and then you know we got
uh some roosters coming in toxic
masculinity it doesn't sound like a
democracy at all no no in fact when um
when Dorothy he was getting uh loved too
much by Roberto because this happens
they get a favorite it ruins their backs
and rips their feathers out so we had to
put her in sex jail and a lot of people
were like why are you putting the victim
in jail and I was like because it's just
chicken Society is different the rooster
is guarding the chickens he does his
thing but but if you take him out then
when they come back in he'll fight with
the other rooster right because they're
going to try and reset a pecking order
so it's the the we have two roosters we
have a bunch of hens and it works
because the younger rooster knows his
place if you take one out and
reintroduce them to adult mature chick
roosters are going to be like I'm gonna
fight it out it's not going to be that
bad people like they're not fighting
roosters it's not going to be like a
rooster fight like people think happens
they'll Chase each other around a bit
and then they'll get to a fight and then
stop but we don't need to do that so
it's easier to take out the one hand and
try getting a bib for her back to
protect it like armor but he kept
flipping the bib off I guess no she
would rip it off she didn't oh oh yeah
yep yep so but uh when Roberto retired
as Roberto Jr will come in and that's
not gonna have that problem and then
we're going to put an immature male who
will view him as the boss and then once
he grows up he'll see him as the boss
and we've got to worry about it so
that's you know we'll be cycling him out
all right let's read some more
we got Bailey and says Jack curious if
you talked with Kelly shubaka of AK
running to take murkowski's seat and
what your opinion of her is also curious
if you guys have tried getting her on
your show I haven't haven't spoken to
her
um directly though I have seen her all
over
um bannon's war room and she goes on
quite frequently Alaska is an
interesting state right and um you know
to understand politically because you'll
have people who like they they they love
smoking weed but they also love guns
right so it's it's sort of this like
quasi it's very very earthy right in
that sense right A lot of people who
love you know very naturalist kind of
society so it's it's different I think
than anything in the lower 48 and that
being said murkowski is very strong
going to be pulling out the stops um do
I think Chewbacca has a real chance of
actually beating her we're looking at um
potentially looking at going back up to
Alaska this year uh do some filming up
there do some shooting talk about some
of the actual
um resources that we have in Alaska I
mean that's America's treasure chest in
terms of Natural Resources you know we
talk about annexing or purchasing
violence right occupy Alaska invade
Alaska go in there actually here Biden
by the way he talks about oh we're going
to start opening up federal leases again
well it's not about where jensaki will
come out and say oh well we can't we
don't need to do drilling because we
already have 9 000 leases out there well
the issue isn't the leases the issue is
the EPA and getting the environmental
approvals to actually drill on the
leases because we went all the way up
with Daniel Turner and we went up to
prudo Bay and you can see the oil rigs
and I didn't know this and you know
whatever
um you know not an expert in oil rigs
but I didn't know that oil rigs were
Mobile on land so they have they have
giant Treads and you can actually drive
it with a joystick like like a like an
actual gigantic Gundam whoa and yeah
dead serious right they I'm like why do
you guys not lead with that right and
and the point and they're all just
sitting around doing nothing wow all
right let's read more we got a sea lion
in Orange says by Pillow was an amazing
book to read such a great book it left
me speechless by Michael Knowles
available
wow amazing Michael Knowles turned
selling his book into a meme and uh I
respect it yeah of course
so there was a notepad in front of Jack
I can take notes now and then he wrote
my pillow on it and put it behind me I
was like do you have anything to
publicize
I just I just want you to buy the pillow
I don't know why you know where can they
get that pillow by the way
clef the misfit says Tim your your quote
only some people have souls theory has
been keeping me up at night NPCs who
can't think independently or see it or
see the machine elves found another
symptom they have no internal monologue
but they'll tell you that it's at the
pineal gland not all of them no all of
them they they've they've done you know
surveys and people they've asked people
do you have an internal monologue do you
like think and talk and like your mind
and there are people say no yeah some
people don't I don't I don't think that
breaks does that break down along are
there any statistics on how that breaks
up based on political views or anything
like that I don't know can we hire
someone no no Joe can we hire like a
polling firm to do that yeah yeah that
would be really really interesting
everyone has souls stop despairing yeah
I wondered if someone's in a lot of pain
if they can't feel it I think every
missiles yeah like if they're not like
it's not like everyone has collected
Souls like everyone has multiple souls
in a jar or something but everyone has a
soul or everyone yeah a body and soul
yeah but you have to develop your soul
you can also kill your soul right you
don't want to do that
I would love to get into that maybe on
the after show I have to think about
that is it yeah well yeah is that how is
that you can actually try to think of
the theological way of describing well
yeah you can you can hmm
all right let's see what do you think
about it Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim
Libs of tick tock is a major player in
the political culture Wharf laws were
written based on the videos she shared
she'll only get bigger now yeah I I
don't know I mean I don't Libs of tick
tock should just be a public figure and
well I think I think they did come out
and set Dylan uh made the announcement
that she is going to be getting hired
with Babylon B oh really oh and that
they are they did do a deal um I had
heard a little bit about this
um so he he tweeted you know basically
put out a tweet thread saying We Stand
by her she will not be canceled her new
job and alluded to the fact that that
Babylon B has done a deal with lives of
tick tock right on all right the user
known as Tim says Tim if doxing is
solely a matter of free speech then
won't then it won't be any issue if we
counter docs every single journalist who
does this nonsense right so I think
doxing is wrong but doxing is Free
Speech you can go outside with a big
poster board of someone's name and
address and private information and
picking it around it is protected speech
um that's why I said I don't think I
think some censorship makes sense and I
think we can all agree that there are
some things like doxing is off limits
the issue is doxing is not a political
opinion it is a form of intimidation
intimidation threat or stochastic
terrorism and as soon as you mix it with
implying that someone's bad and then you
docs in the same article that's
political when you're talking about
someone's values and making value claims
on someone in public that's a political
move yeah I think I think doxing um I
have no problem with doxing not being on
social media doxing is not a personal
opinion doxing is not a political
opinion doxing is not speech in the
sense that it's uh it's not political
speech it is just posting some the
information well this is under under the
minimize harm Theory you know and I will
say too I'm not an absoluteist in this
I'm willing to hear some counterpoints
because allowing someone to determine
when they can ban you based on doxing
could also restrict you from publishing
newsworthy events that aren't doxing but
could well so so as an example though uh
doctin can also be revealing someone's
name not necessarily their but just
their address so if you get these viral
videos
um not just lose a tick tock type videos
but let's say a video of a criminal act
and you have the ability to actually
positively identify the person in one of
these attacks we see like uh attacks on
Asians or shooting or you know whatever
it is you can identify that person
that's not doxing therein lies right the
Big Challenge I do disagree with
publishing the name in these stories
because it doesn't serve the story
itself it's an attack I have no problem
with if you know Taylor Lorenz wrote an
opinion piece saying here's my opinion
of this person and I'm publishing their
name specifically because I want you to
know it I'd be like you know they're
asking that we should probably say this
but there actually is a story to be be
told about lives of Tick Tock but the
story would be why did the account take
off what was the content they were
dealing with why were laws written what
was the impact of it but that wasn't the
story yeah all right John Kristen says
or is it uh yes Kristen love Pozo by far
my favorite guest on IRL despite him
talking smack on my hometown Altoona and
cargo shorts Altoona PA
shout out to Altoona yeah that was fun
right yeah that was Al tuna was fun that
was a little ribbing that was a little
rude but not about cargo shorts cargo
shorts absolutely unacceptable
dalamar says the question is simple why
did all of these old papers and media
just become the National Enquirer over
the last 10 years has the internet just
ravaged them that much yes waiting for
the New York Times and wapo article
finding Hitler's skull
yeah I wouldn't be surprised I mean
we're already at that level where it's
like an activist gets hired and then
blogs and they're like national news it
used to be there are three networks that
were held very tightly as The
Gatekeepers ABC NBC CBS and then when it
splurged out into all these millions of
people giving the news now it's about
who's the most entertaining who's going
to catch your eye with spectacle yeah
but that's actually that's actually more
traditional that so the the
um the centralization of news is only
something that really came about with
the Advent of Television
um prior to to that every town had like
three or four newspapers a bunch of
radio stations and or even you know if
you go back even further pamphlets and
so
um yellow journalism the Spanish uh
Spanish-American War 1898 is is always
talked about as one of these things of
who could make the biggest splash you
could say oh the Spaniards are against
us they're blowing up the main in Havana
Harbor they're doing all this stuff
we've got to go against them
um so the idea of viewpoint neutral
journalism actually is something that
only only arose really with the Advent
of television in the 1950s to early
1960s coincides of course with the
Vietnam War
um but that's that's not the traditional
American View and really experience with
media that's only something that arose
because of that one limited very limited
interaction if you go back to today's of
course the anniversary of the Battle of
Lexington and Concord the shot heard
around the world and if we remember it
was those
localized pamphlets independent printers
independent Publishers Thomas Payne you
know printing stuff and handing it out
to people in Inns and taverns that
really formulated the sort of the
thought experiment behind the American
Revolution that led to the independence
of this country yeah
all right Dan says Tim big big fan of
you and the team Tim cast subscriber and
enjoy the extras although I don't take
advantage of the membership I will never
cancel out of support for what you and
the team do thank you what we need to do
next is uh uh it's a lot we're juggling
so much pop culture crisis of course has
been you know getting getting bigger
getting more views getting more subs so
we want we want to have that show that
that engages with pop culture getting
getting bigger because that's how we're
going to impact it by participating
but um we need to hire prominent writers
who do good op-eds analysis and think
pieces so that we can start making
opinion paywalled articles for
timcast.com so that way we can share
these stories and then be like hey
here's you know like a value proposition
we have a lot of users we have a lot of
subscribers The overwhelming majority
are subscribing for the general Mission
and content of the website and it's not
necessarily just about the members only
stuff it's just like it's it's the news
team it's the writing we do it's it's
the whole mission
we know this because we had subscribers
even before we had the pay we always had
to do that to create a better value
proposition so that's the next thing I
probably I want to hire two opinion
writers in cultural politics so we're
looking at a handful of people and then
they'll write articles when they you
know when they write articles addressing
big stories like this and then those
will be like pay well to op-eds just to
give the members more stuff plus we have
the green room and we're we're trying to
expand and grow and do crazy stuff
Matthew Yemen says Babylon B CEO Seth
Dillon announced his partnership with
Libs of tick tock I think it's a good
fit I really do
all right
Placid Saint says Netflix may have gone
down because a new series called he's
expecting just got released and it looks
super cringe and looks like utter gutter
trash
I can only imagine what what that one's
about
we'll see
it's an affront to God
not the only thing on Netflix either no
no
all right uh let's see Sean McCormick
says there are trending rumors that Dr
fauci is facing a Military Tribunal from
April 18th please look into this it
could be huge and it's definitely not
happening and I would bet a lot of money
is not happening
I mean that's just come on that's like
Wiki world news level yeah yeah yeah
yeah nope sorry bad boys
servers in Germany CIA gun battle level
yeah
Ben Hickson says in Oz major parties
pulled 33 independent making other third
all Aussies vote major parties last to
enact real change and consider liberal
Democrats with freedom Manifesto
interesting I thought they meant Dr Oz
for a second who's you know the guy who
supports red flag laws who talked about
Top surgery for seventh graders who uh
mocked heartbeat bills and yet somehow I
was running around calling himself
conservative even though to run in
Pennsylvania even though of course he's
lived for 30 years in New Jersey yeah I
mean he's got a with those opinions he's
got to wait like at least five years
before he calls himself conservative
maybe six yeah maybe six
times an illusion Steve says we can
really go back to the way it was if
you're pushing 60 like me way better
times when I was a kiddo I would be
terrified if I was a parent today
it's there you know I think we
romanticize the past you could
cell phones are great every generation
there's people think it's the end of the
world it's com it's I would say it's
common it's not common throughout every
person alive at that moment it's very
few people do it but right now they have
a megaphone don't get distracted by it
don't get afraid stay Brave man you're
live you're doing it you're here with us
now we we had a draft during Vietnam
think about that we had an actual draft
in this country where you were you were
conscripted by the government and there
was a lottery system
um with essentially you were given a
number and then you would turn on TV at
night
um for your local Lottery and if your
number came up off you went four in the
morning yeah or in the morning so my dad
has told the story when he was in high
school in the morning announcements they
would play the radio segment announcing
who in the area had their number pulled
like so they would know who they would
read the numbers and then you would just
go crazy
the Gulf of Tonkin that's right and it's
crazy that people would just stand up
and be like oh guess I'm gonna go
democracy right guys democracy you
understand they did that on purpose they
put us into that war on purpose they did
that on purpose and then they drafted
people
yes all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says
Ian roll the dice while we wait please
one through a hundred here we go
all right Ian's Gonna Roll that I'm
gonna scroll down
74. 74 ain't not bad big number
all right you know grafty says Bach yeah
you back grafty has been a generous
supporter of chicken City keeping those
chickens well fed thank you very much we
now have uh so chicken city has Sky eggs
what are sky eggs they're they're these
eggs that dispense treats and they hang
and when you give five bucks in
different order they will drop treats so
when every hundred dollars a chicken
party is triggered and like dance lights
show up and a dance song happens and
then the treats drop all randomly
chickens are all running around yeah
when they come running out of the when
they hear the music and they come
running it's really funny when the music
starts and they run from outside and
they're like waddling like
we heard the song so they learned the
Chicken Dance song I think I was
watching it a little bit and I think I
saw Sheamus actually running along with
the chickens yeah you know look every
now and again there's there's bread on
the ground a fella gets hungry you just
have to take your chances hey those are
sky treats people don't realize that
yeah Sheamus pecks the ground and eats
the crumbs he does look and also you
know if a chicken gets in my way I'm not
about fighting it it's good exercise too
Murph try says Tim please tell Brett I
apologize for calling him event
yesterday thanks Murph so so uh you know
Brett was here yesterday yeah yeah the
Super Chat I said he said Brent and then
Braxton who was here called him Brent as
well because he thought he must have
been wrong yeah
Proto says people don't understand the
plus part of the service get CNN for
free every every month or get CNN plus
no stelter for for just five bucks more
no that's CNN plus plus I'm pretty sure
celtzer's on CNN Plus
like you pay extra for him not to be
honest
yo like nobody watches this show
pretty good it's it's like what's his
ratings like forty thousand his ratings
are abysmal and and they say that John
Malone so who's the who's the um the
lead investor or the shareholder in
Discovery has said that you know he just
thinks that uh that's Delta is just like
a cancer on the company and wants to get
rid of him really oh 100 but honestly I
mean I think there's
people who are on there because Brian
stelter has no influence Brian Selter
has no impact I mean he's kind of just
like a laughing clown right everybody
just jokes about that guy he's a punch
line is he like a really nice guy in
private why is it not so popular over
there what would you do if like the
discovery guys came to you Jack and they
were like we want you to run CNN take it
over uh I would ask for full-carb launch
yeah yeah I would I would say look you
know yeah like I have to you know I so
yeah first thing you do you got a clean
house that's that's first and foremost
and so in Poland
um when the law and Justice party which
is like the center right party won
um the control of the government in
2015. the first thing they did was
essentially go to the Polish version of
like the BBC which they call TVP and
they just fired all the on-air talent
and they brought in conservatives to
basically be the broadcasters of Poland
and you know essentially you'd have to
do that with CNN or at least you know
bring on people so you'd have to have
your your news programs that were just
straight news and if you caught someone
embellishing you'd have to get rid of
them
um and then you could have multiple
shows you could go back by the way right
it wasn't that long ago that Alex Jones
was going on CNN debating Piers Morgan
or you would have Tucker Carlson sitting
down with like James Carville or someone
from the left right you can easily bring
that back and you know and you can have
Don Lemon and Wolf Blitzer arguing about
which black hole image 370 went through
if CNN had Alex Jones and say Alex Jones
went on The View I know I know if they
had Alex Jones and Rachel Maddow on the
same show at the same time they'd have
like Mega ratings 10 million got to be
long form they should go long form too
there's so many things you could there's
so many things you could do with that
and everybody would want to watch it and
be way more interesting than more in
politics all the time don't give him
ideas because you know well we already
kind of did that like we had Rachel
Maddow on with Jeremy yeah we did that's
true so uh so uh that's right yeah
Rachel Maddow and Jeremy boring
discussing philosophy Rachel of course
is a conservative white man
named who wrote a book called speechless
no no here's something funny so whenever
a guest comes we have our graphic artist
Jessica draws a portrait of them right
and then they sign it so for Michael
Knowles she actually made a Rachel
Maddow photo and a Michael Knowles photo
and Michael only signed The Rachel
Maddow
but all right did he write Rachel Maddow
he was like
that's beneath me I guess on the wall of
portraits we have here we got to put up
the uh Rachel maddowell
yeah it's probably worth more money now
to be honest it's like the variant we'll
get Rachel to sign Michael's yeah there
you go
all right mjac says interested in what
all of you even my fellow fellow
Catholics think of the dark Maga
movement I don't know what that is what
is that
I've seen yes uh Raheem Kasam had a sub
stack up about this and the Newsweek is
attacking it now and it's sort of this
like
it's like this new take on Maga and it's
the idea that like it basically it comes
down to if Trump comes back it should be
like a Revenge Mission oh that you know
and and so all the Aesthetics kind of
you know you know revolve around that
Trump just shows up and he's wearing
like a black trench coat and his eyes
have like yeah
well no the thing I was saying yesterday
was you saw that that bit with um you
know Joe Biden and the Easter Bunny
um coming off you know in the Easter
Bunny was like getting him out of there
and I was saying well the the next
logical step in that would be that the
the Easter Bunny pulls the mask off and
underneath it's Trump and you know the
Crowd Goes Wild how did he get in here
and you know he was like well God it's
Trump it's Trump I need a uh Emperor
Palpatine but Trump oh my gosh it seems
like I feel like he looks more like Vine
no no come on give me the dude do it oh
do the impression yeah As Trump trump as
Emperor Palpatine this story of dark
plague at the wise is the greatest I
don't
I don't Trump's voice
like quite frankly it's a story see that
wouldn't tell you
firstly okay folks defeat you have to
let the head flood through you he's too
dangerous be Left Alive yeah I can't
it's not the Jedi way do it your friends
are the sanctuary
I said I said look if you if you entered
if you entered you create airspace we we
would use the Death Star at a 10 meant
it we may have used the Death Star if
they went to Ukraine it's possible of
course and uh deserved it
yeah I'm pretty sure he blows it up
right I don't know oh let's jump in the
shark didn't he blow Corson up in the
first one no that was awesome yeah I'm
pretty sure of course like it's blown up
in the new one I guess it's like it's
like a throwaway line like oh yeah we
blew up the capital city well this time
this time the death star's a planet and
it doesn't fire one blast it fires a
bunch it's like yeah real original guys
all right Amber black says chicken City
should sponsor h3h3 done Ethan oh have
your people call my people chicken City
will absolutely sponsor one of your
episodes I am not kidding send me your
rights if they're if they're reasonable
I mean if they're like we want some
insane number but if they legitimately
are like here's our normal rates I'll be
like dude we want the chicken City
commercial we want the chicken City
shout out from Ethan Klein I will take
it chicken city is the most most
wholesome show completely apolitical it
is just chickens eating treats being
chickens we're actually making kids
cartoons and I wrote the chicken City
theme song
we also got the funniest like Adult Swim
2007 chicken cartoon for like 20 or 30
seconds but it's a little too too racy
for uh Instagram I'll just say that when
Sheamus and I when Sheamus and I were
doing the vo like writing session on
this I ad-libbed a very very very dark
and then when I sent the end of the the
vo to our animator Kent I was like hey
don't make that one yeah I was like I
will not do that and then he sends me he
sends me the clip like it has been made
and it's hilarious I tried posting on
Instagram but Instagram what was that
what was that show it was like um Adam
carolla's on it he was a pig
all right we got JN who says Magneto Ian
watch Dr Gene Kim talk about graphene
regarding iron mixing with Clay McLeod
Sheamus can help him understand Deuces
all right thank you and McLeod
I appreciate the shout out I don't
understand the reference is that is that
a Highlander you know what send me a
link on Twitter to the video you're
talking there can be only one yeah thank
you there can be only one only one man
what a show or movie or both whatever it
is a show like every episode he like he
killed the guy or something because
they're gonna be only one it's so weird
like we just like go around killing
everyone else well I know in the first
movie they um they have this this like
huge epic drawn out Scottish Highlander
battle in like a parking garage and I
think that in general we need to do more
to
um be more grateful to parking garages
for their contribution to the movies of
the 1970s and 80s yeah it's got a lot of
good lighting opportunities like
everything since Watergate had to be
everything was in a parking garage
I thought the uh they live had a great
fight scene right outside of a park
right outside
all right Honda driven says hey guys I
love the show and just became a member
thank you very much thoughts on Russell
Brand's podcast yesterday about the
great reset if you've watched it I
haven't but Russell Brand has been
hitting Grand Slams lately hasn't he his
whole life he's actually he's actually
really really good in death on the Nile
he's like probably the best part of that
movie he's so good he's like a probably
excellent in that he's like a master and
he's not it's not a comedic role either
it's like a very serious
um dramatic turn and I love how they're
smearing them they're like Russell Brand
is now far right I was so glad he got
serious in like 2011. he started to take
stuff really seriously right around the
time they were going to sell us out to
the trans-pacific partnership isn't that
right when he and uh Katy Perry broke up
yeah yeah I think so
changes it man all right seven changes a
man seven ninja says Tim will you ever
do more Tech news on your main Channel
or maybe on a sub channel for example
maybe there is news on development of
geothermal energy well what we're trying
to do is make new shows and we're also
trying to figure out the right way to do
it because we want we want timcast.com
to be big but also does it make sense
for people who are you know driven by
culture and politics to you know see a
story about a new cell phone they might
be like so we do do we do a broad
General website or do we make like a
network site and each individual like
show has its own site with its own
articles and stuff and like verticals
yeah yeah so you know I think we're at
the point where we couldn't justify
launching independent websites just yet
but we're probably going to get close to
that
so there will probably be you know
timcast.com which is like this show and
my my YouTube show and then a little bit
of everything but then we'll probably
give independent sites so we will we we
have been planning a tech show
because we have a hacker space that's
Barren and unused we just need hackers
to be in it we have one of the best 3D
printers money can buy which is just
sitting there unused I'm disappointed
but uh expansion is not easy you know
man we like I don't want to say too much
but security stuff like expanding all of
that
it's brutal it's brutal man that being
said I do think I saw a headline on
energy that uh something about the the
bite Administration was looking about at
spending 7 billion on um refurbishing
nuclear sites in the U.S well you know
our economy is doing well why not why
not spend a whole lot of money just
print it keep written it's a good idea
all right we'll grab uh one more
skater-owned solution says Tim I'm down
to my last dollars to give hope to catch
your attention to get some advice on how
I want to rebuild skate culture in the
right direction please check out my
story on the
skater-owned.solutions website or
someone on your team we need people who
can build ramps
so you know if you uh if you guys do
ramp construction we have a lot of stuff
that has to get built oh yeah you can
email us spend theofo gmail.com if you
do ramp construction send us photos of
the work you've done and we will hire
you yesterday to do construction for
your oh for your personal work man take
a look at Brett dasovich because that
dude is diligent every day he skates and
he makes videos and he pushes it out and
he sells himself and then Tim saw his
work so do that as well actually what
happened was over the pandemic
rollerblading became way more popular
because people started getting back into
it sales started going up and then I
watched skateboarding videos but because
of the similarities I started getting
recommended roller skating and
rollerblading and that's actually how I
found Brett I saw this video where he
was like doing a grind on like a wooden
stump or something and I was like this
dude's willing like he'll get anything
and so I hit him up I'm like hey come
out and film because we also had a
scooter guy come out a BMX Guy come out
I was like I want to get everybody to
like you know and then Brett stuck
around and we got him on pop culture
crisis so anyway my friends smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
support the work we do at timcast.com
because your membership isn't just about
necessarily what the website has to
offer it does but it's about the mission
that we're building and trying to expand
so you know hopefully you believe in the
work we do and if you do you want to
keep it going so that's what your
membership gets and you will get to
watch the members only segment coming up
at about 11 pm tonight you can follow
the show at Tim cast IRL basically
everywhere follow us on Instagram for
Clips you can follow me at timcast
basically everywhere Jack you have a
book
by Pillow I just would like to remind
everyone to buy pillow every page of the
book says bite but no seriously uh check
me out human events daily wherever you
get your podcasts
um we are got a new tagline for the show
it's a podcast for people who don't like
podcasts because it's 25 minutes all the
news the analysis of the day and our
promise our oath our solemn vow to
everyone be good be brief be gone
right on wonderful uh I have a YouTube
channel called Freedom tunes please go
over there check it out I think you guys
will enjoy it we just released a cartoon
today uh called the Democrats brilliant
midterm strategy I don't want to give
away the punch line it's very short 30
seconds or so I think you guys will
really like us follow me Ian
crossland.net if you want to get in
touch and if you want to talk more about
this uh twisting universe theory please
contact me on minds or Twitter get
involved very fun very exciting future
we have ahead of us bye cool and I am
also here in the corner you guys may
follow me on Twitter and minds.com at
sour patchlets I also have a sour patch
lid stop me
all right everybody head over to
timcast.com for that members segment and
we'll see you all there thanks for
hanging out bye guys